good evening everybody
and welcome to this virtual meeting of
the council
may i first remind you all of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that your microphones are
muted
when you are not speaking that you do
not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use the
messaging chat function
during the meeting unless it is to
report a pecuniary non-pecuniary
interest
or to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave additionally
you will be invited to speak and ask
questions by the chair
please await your turn if members lose
connection to the meeting
that they must contact the member
support officer mandy smith
as soon as possible as this is the
virtual meeting
you will not need to stand to address
the chair
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting
will be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
presentation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented
to being filmed by entering this meeting
you're also consenting to being filmed
by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and
sound recordings for webcasting and
or training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda now please
apologies for absence thank you chair i
have received apologies for absence from
councillor hinton and councillor gould
all other councillors are present thank
you
thank you declaration of interest by
councillors
are there any
are there any declarations of interest
counsellors
thank you item 3
bc 2015 to confirm the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting
held on 10th november 2020
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
[Music]
could i have a proposal please
i'll propose um adrian osborne
councillor osborne
thank you very much thank you and
councillor john ward are you
seconding i'll second yes thank you
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair
councillors could you please open the
vote in the modern.gov app by clicking
the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen and
selecting attendance and voting in the
voting tab for this agenda item it will
show in blue please click on the blue
line to open the vote
thank you
[Music]
we're just waiting for the results of
the vote
cancer and dawson and councillor norman
we're still awaiting um your vote
please can you vote as soon as possible
thank you yeah sorry um i did i did have
my hand up um it's saying that i'm not
eligible to vote for some reason
and that has just changed this second so
that's absolutely fine
uh jennifer i'm pressing plus and mine
says more open related documents and
they're already open
okay would you like to just say how you
would like to vote and we'll add that in
manually
oh in favor thank you
councillor adrian osborne you've got
your hand up is there a reason for that
i don't believe i have madam chairman
but oh it's down now thank you
that was a lot of hand yeah thanks chair
we had now have the result of the vote
there's 28
four and two abstentions thank you thank
you
so the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed
and will be signed at the next practical
opportunity
item 4 bc 2016
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on 24th
november 2020 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
yes chair councilman crawl
could you um thank you would you like to
listen
thank you i just noticed in uh item 33
10 on page 24
the sentence reads i t intuitive had to
be key
uh if the addition of the word being
intuitive
i believe would be correct
yes thank you what's the substantive
point thank you but we'll get that
altered so are there any other
amendments
or comments that need to be made please
so taking into consideration that very
minor amendment
uh could we have a proposal please
thank you councillor adrian osborne are
you proposing
i am proposing thank you madam chairman
thank you thank you may i have a
seconder please
may i have a second please i'll second
again if you'd like
thank you council award
so thank you i will now ask the
corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
so we're voting on that paper with that
minor amendment
thank you thank you chair councillors
can you please open the vote again in
the modern.gov app by clicking the plus
sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen and
selecting attendance and voting
and then in the voting tab this agenda
item will show in blue please click on
that blue line to open the boat
thank you
by just waiting for the votes to be um
submitted
just one more vote to come
councillor lindsay we're still awaiting
your vote are you able to vote please
apologies
i will
well i'll vote for i think it's easier
if i
thank you
chair that is 29 4 and one abstention
thank you
thank you so the minutes of the meeting
have been confirmed and will be signed
at the next practicable opportunity
item five bc 2017
announcement from the chairman and
leader
um from my point of view obviously i
haven't been able to attend
many events on behalf of the council due
for
due to obvious reasons but i refer you
to paper bc
2017 for noting thank you
council award do you have anything to
report
yes i do madam chairman thank you very
much thank you
this second coveted wave is clearly now
much worse than the first last spring
we are in the third lockdown and it is
going to be a long time before we will
be
will be out of the woods suffolk has
been badly hit like all regions
fortunately all districts in the county
including ipswich are at last showing a
steady
and significant decrease over the past
few days the latest data from the
suffolk corona watch site shows that
here in baber
the infection rate is now 411.8 per
hundred thousand
in total we've had three thousand one
hundred and thirty seven confirmed cases
and sadly hundred and thirty two deaths
since that time since the pandemic began
although this latin number is the latest
data from the ons news only up to the
first of january
we must continue with the public
awareness and messaging campaign
and follow the lockdown rules but the
vaccination program is underway
and accelerating which is really good
news
the new closed business lockdown payment
grants are now available
and we have started to pay them and the
tier four grants to qualifying
businesses
the grant situation has become quite
complex as there are several that
continue to be available
full details have been published on our
website including a comprehensive
infographic describing them all you will
have received an email from the suffolk
and north
east essex integrated care system today
inviting you to our covert briefing
tomorrow at 6pm
this is the first in a series by a panel
of local health leaders to keep us all
updated with the latest position about
covert and the progress and progress of
the vaccination program
before we debate the petition that we
have received from hadley regarding
short-term parking charges
i just want to address another petition
that we received from thomas morelli in
sudbury as you know
our constitution governs the rules to
validate a petition to avoid fraud and
unfortunately this petition
as submitted contravened those rules i
know that this has disappointed many
people
including some of you but the rejection
of this petition on these
grounds is consistent with our rejection
of previous petitions for the same
reason
if we hadn't ignored those rules others
would demand the same leeway
and the petition scheme would collapse
however i know that this is a difficult
and sensitive matter
and we have considered carefully how we
might find a reasonable way forward in
line with our constitution
whilst also recognizing the efforts that
mr morelli has gone
in capturing a section of public feeling
on these issues
we did therefore invite him to speak
today on the hadley parking petition
but unfortunately he declined now we
cannot let kobe be used as it
is an excuse to stop us from doing
things as many have suggested
our normal business must continue and
difficult decisions
must be faced in respect of the bellevue
land and house sale
mr morelli's petition request to delay
consideration
is actually consistent with our timeline
as this matter will be considered by
cabinet on 11th of march
i would also like to explain some more
about what is happening with the subject
access point
firstly the future of this has already
been decided an officer delegated
decision was made on 1st
december and the details of this have
been published on our website
councillor parker explained the
situation very clearly in his email to
all members on 18th december
the current service level agreement in
sudbury town council is due to expire at
the end of march
the time council wanted us to pay a
significant increased amount for them to
continue to run service
a new agreement couldn't be reached
because we simply cannot pay an
increased sum
for a diminishing service we therefore
had to make a decision regarding our
future intentions
we couldn't allow the current agreement
to expire without making provision for
its replacement
the consequence of doing so would be
that no access point of any sort would
exist from first of april
but most importantly this now gives us
the opportunity
to provide a different service that
focuses more on our customer strategy
details of a replacement access point
with a continuing face-to-face service
in a new location are being finalized
and we will be informing members of the
details
in the very near future when this is
done i'm sure that most of us will agree
that we will have done the right thing
for our residents
finally i want to take the opportunity
to say that
debate and even demonstrations are
legitimate ways to protest and express
opposition to policies
what is not legitimate or acceptable are
attacks on my or any other member's home
neither is relentless personal online
abuse
nor the recent public comments about
shooting baba councillors made by two
hadley town councillors last week
although i accept that they were made in
jest these things
are counterproductive the increasing
coarseness of political debate
fueled by intolerable levels of levels
of online abuse
the politicians at all levels receive
should worry us all
it inevitably encourages some to believe
that violence is an acceptable form of
protest
thank you madam chairman
thank you council award we've decided to
add a new
section to our meeting this evening
and give members the opportunity
to um clarify have any items they wish
clarified um on our leaders report
so if any counsellor has any points that
they want clarified or any questions
that they'd like to
make to council award in his position as
leader
then we do so at this point so
do any counsellors have any questions or
points they want to clarify
councillors yes
thank you very much chair yes um it
really it is to do with the access
center and you said i have the figures
in front of me
and um about the cost and you said that
we were charging you more in fact that
is
wrong so i'd like you to assess that
because it's um we had um
initially we had 74 000
2021 it was 55 000
and um so really that that doesn't give
people the right picture
and and including with that um
how can you um give us figures about
what's going to do and you said
in the final decision that it would be a
better a better
service how can you better what we've
already got how do you think the staff
feel about that
thank you john um well as i said we will
be providing members with
full details of the new service and um
you will see that it's more it will be
more in line with our customer strategy
as as i described and will be a better
service
so um i guess you just got to wait and
and see what we are going to provide
there um in sudbury
can i come back there chair yeah um yes
but
you are saying it's a better service
despite
loads of emails and phone calls from me
you have not said
where it is going to be and even if you
only gave us 50 000
at sudbury town council it'd be better
than what you're going to provide
this is so negative i find it appalling
okay well thank you for your uh comment
counselor as as i said um when we've got
the details
ready we will be able to provide those
to all councillors in the very near
future
thank you council award and thank you
councillor ayers
um adrian osborne um you've had your
hand up for some time have you got a
question that you'd like to
um ask councillor ward
i don't know madam chairman according to
my uh screen i haven't
i haven't got my hand okay okay thank
you oh
look i'll press it on now is that on or
off
it's off oh well so when it goes ray's
hand it goes lower on my screen
i see it i see it chair is on oh no
now it's on now it's on now it's off
yeah i think
i think there's some delay here now it's
off okay
yes thank you so are there councillor
creswell have you got a question that
you'd like to
make to council award yes i i
i sort of agree with sue um it has to be
a question
sorry um okay sorry um or a
qualification
okay chair sorry um what i would say was
about three years ago
the advice center was open at sudbury
and i think
it was done to the tune of about a
hundred thousand pound
now there's quotes being um
saying between thirty thousand and fifty
thousand to set up
something advice center somewhere else
now how do that
how does that work viable to to move
something which has already cost
the council 100 000 to move that
somewhere else which is going to cost
another 30 to 50
000. does how does that work and how
many hours
do you expect the people to work in the
new conditions
to what we've got now thank you
i don't have the information about the
hours i'll be able to get that back to
you
um i would like to point out that we're
talking about an access point not an
advice center
thank you
an access service or we in sudbury we
call it an advice center and you call it
a
customer access point but but we're
seeing off the same page it's the same
thing we
we're trying to provide a service for
the residents of sudbury in the
surrounding villages thank you
okay thank you councillor croswell
councillor alison owen
have you got a question or unless you
want clarifying
thank um yeah
question to john um what i'm going to
ask is how have you assessed
how your your new service of the advice
center stroke access point
will meet the growing needs of the most
vulnerable members of our community
i will have to get that question
answered for you council
owen that'll have to be referred to the
assistant director for
customers
is that going to be answered now council
award but
um or or outside them i would
i would say we will provide a response
later
outside the meeting okay thank you so
council owen that will be
provided for you after the meeting okay
um well i'd like to sort of come back on
that anyway i'd like to say the people
come to our advice center are the ones
that need
a one-to-one service this is some
something that cannot be lost
no and we will be providing face-to-face
contact
so um i i think this is
uh we're now going over old ground i
think now
so uh if there any if there is any other
matter for clarification
um we can move to that but otherwise i
think we'll close this section of the
meeting
i did i did have my hand up oh okay
councillor barrett
is there a matter you want clarifying
please i just wasn't um surprised
to hear uh councillor awards uh saying
that
uh the sudbury town council were
intended to increase the
the charge do you mean that it was going
to revert to the original
charge that was in place john
can you clarify that yes
that is my understanding okay
thank you thank you that's right
councillor mayberry
um you have your hand up um yes i have
um and thank you very very
yes my question is could the leader
describe fully how a service could be
better
without any experience of it please
we will be providing the details of the
new service very shortly
can i may i come back chairman
if it's for clarification yes it is
um i am not aware of any
other council that would actually
insist on closing one service
before they have full details for the
leader
of how a new service would be run i'm
really surprised
that you do not have an answer thank you
so unless you want to um come back on
that council award i think we'll move on
from this lecture
yeah so we're going to um move on from
this section of the meeting
now because i think um hands that are up
have already had an opportunity to
um have their their uh queries clarified
so we'll now move on to the next
item on the agenda item
six to receive notification of petitions
in accordance with council procedure
rules
thank you chair there are no validated
petitions received thank you
item six a petition for debate
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
to report and debate the following
petition
containing at least 1 000 valid
signatures
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
i'll now read out the petition that we
have received and has been validated
the title is free parking hadley
we the undersigned petition the council
to maintain the free parking in all
hadley car parks
it is now more essential than ever for
the vitality and future
of hadley high street to enable local
and visiting shoppers
to park free of charge a number of new
outlets
have only just opened and to impinge
businesses
sustainability by the introduction of
parking charges
would be completely retrograde
any decisions of this nature should only
take place
after the fullest public consultation
that is the end of the wording of the
petition
the monitoring officer will now detail
the process to be followed for the
debate
thank you to our monitoring officer
thank you chair and good evening
councillors the process for petitions
being presented to full council for
debate can be found under part b
of section 3.1 of the petitions policy
which is contained within the
constitution
the petition organizer will be invited
to present the petition
for up to three minutes we have also
received two
questions from hadley town council and a
member of the public
which relate to the same subject matter
as the petition
so the chairman has agreed to vary the
order of business on the agenda
to take these questions at the same time
as the petition
the relevant portfolio holder will be
then invited to respond to these
questions
and respond to the petition for up to
three minutes
following that the local ward
councillors will be invited to respond
to the petition for up to three minutes
and as the overview and scrutiny
committee has recently considered
a proposed parking policy report the
chairman of the overview and scrutiny
committee
will then be invited to report any
comments of the committee
which are relevant to the petition
debate
all other members will then be able to
speak once
for up to three minutes subject to the
time limitation
in the policy this time limitation is 30
minutes
however the chairman has decided to use
her discretion to extend it to up to 60
minutes
during the course of the council's
debate on the petition
the council may decide to make a
decision to vote in support of the
petition
or to vote against the petition
either of these options will require a
motion to be moved
seconded and voted upon however because
we are using the rules of debate for the
petitions policy
a councillor who moves uh such a motion
will be doing so in their ordinary three
minutes
um for speaking there will not be an
additional
speaking slot for any mover or seconder
of such emotion
if no such motion is proposed and voted
upon
the default position is that the council
notes the petition
as parking is an executive function
the petition will automatically be
referred to the cabinet
when it takes its decision on parking
policy
furthermore because this is an executive
function the council cannot resolve
to take any other action in respect of
the petition
councillors i'd just like to remind you
that this debate is limited to the
submitted petition
it is not a debate about parking issues
more widely
however it may be necessary for
councillors to refer to wider parking
strategies
which are relevant to the context of the
petition
the chairman will manage the debate
accordingly to ensure that it
remains focused on the petition
thank you chair
[Music]
thank you i would now like to invite the
petition organizer
mr lang or a representative
to present the petition for up to three
minutes
mr lang i believe you're present
okay you got me oh yes we have thank you
right um please present your petition
where i've already read it
so you can um proceed with what you want
to say about it
thank you okay well thank you chair and
to all those that have signed a petition
whilst other
councils across the country are
introducing periods of free parking to
try and encourage football
in the high street this cabinet having
established
the average parking time is 64 minutes
have cynically seeked to
charge after only 30 minutes labor's own
q a page has a link to the association
of town
and city management to a report they
clearly attach some weight to
from that report rugby council are
working with retailers
to ship to to shape parking retailers
can issue permits to customers
for four hours free parking
another example not from the report t's
valley have just this month introduced
free parking from minimum
stay of two hours up to a maximum of
three hours
this policy to be in place for two years
t valley mayor has said something i
think we'd all agree with everyone
across our region
deserves a vibrant and thriving high
street that can still flourish in an age
of online shopping
they are the lifeblood of our area and
introducing free parking
can help make them even more dynamic and
a vibrant place
to live and do business
from the statutory guidance for local
authorities on enforcing parking
restrictions and i quote
the secretary of state recommends
enforcement authorities which they
are to consult locally on their parking
policies
when they appraise them they should seek
the views of people and businesses with
a range of different
parking needs including the views of the
police
it goes on the appraisal should take
account of the impact on the local
economy
and the viability of local shops and
high streets
to my knowledge none of this has
happened
the british retail consortium have
warned of conditions getting worse for
non-essential shops
and the high street generally retail
figures for 2020
are the worst on record except for food
and online
the center for retail research has said
2020 was the worst for high street job
losses in 25 years
this proposal its present form
fails it fails for not engaging with tan
and parish councils
it fails you're not engaging with local
businesses
or the general public and it fails to
not take into account the demise in the
high street
and the need to rebuild this meeting
can and should be the start of that
engagement and collaboration
so i had urged the cabinet to think
again and to delay any decision
and to delay any decision until a more
inclusive proposal
is forthcoming thank you thank you
thank you mr lang before we move to
debate
i would now like to invite the mayor of
hadley frank mins
to ask a question on behalf of hadley
town council
relating to this issue
councilman are you available i'm here
you hear me alright
yes we can hear you yeah thank you um
in the light of the widespread
opposition to the introduction of
short-term parking charges in hadley
illustrated by the petition that uh mr
lang is just so ably
put before you does the council now
agree
that the proposal should be withdrawn
and a coherent plan for parking across
the town be developed through
consultation with hadley town council
and had a residence thank you
thank you councilmans i'd like to invite
council marvey
to respond to the question from hadley
town council
council easy thank you very much madam
chairman
as i explained uh at the overview and
scrutiny committee yesterday
um having carefully listened to their
debate
and i will listen to the debate this
evening and i note councillor min's
comments
and suggestions i do anticipate that the
proposal being considered by cabinet in
february
will differ greatly to the current
proposal
thank you madam chairman thank you
councilman
do you have a supplementary question
related to the original question
uh no i'm i'm somewhat heartened by uh
councillor malveezy's response
obviously um i'm sure she's not prepared
to say at this stage
what the great differences will be uh
but
that is a step forward for which i'm
grateful thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you councilman
nonprofesi too
i would now like to invite uh mr europa
young
who is a resident to ask his question
mr young are you available please i hope
so can you hear me
yes we can thank you excellent
i'll start by noting uh in your papers
that the overview and securities
committee
actually are suggesting that the parking
management principles and interventions
detailed in appendix a be implemented
no sooner than the first of september
2021.
now my question is how is it sensible
to implement the changes in appendix a
before the results of the comprehensive
parking strategy review
is completed and publicly reviewed
surely the implementation should wait
for the results
of the strategic review otherwise both
time and money
might be spent implementing unnecessary
procedures
and creating confusion for the public
thank you mr young council malthusie
please can you respond
yes thank you madam chairman the
difference between the strategy
the parking strategy review including
for
future paths being steered by
development requirements
and what we are doing now is that this
is a current
needs analysis appendix a demonstrates
what we need to
and should be doing right now the
strategy
looks ahead it looks at future needs our
needs in five to ten years if not longer
thank you madam chairman thank you
councilman mulvey
mr young do you have a supplementary
question
uh which might relate to your original
question
yes it does um and thank you councillor
malvizi for
pointing out to me what strategy means
um but i i come from a
base where in management you need to
first get the facts now none of us know
now what the new norm will be
uh when kovitz subsides we don't know
how the public's
shopping habits will change or what the
high street would look like do you have
a question mr yes the question
is can the council abort the current
parking
proposals until we have the reliable
data
that the strategy document
should produce
comes off easy thank you madam chairman
um earlier last year the council passed
the climate change action plan and a
biodiversity action plan
and in that we need to
incorporate adopt recognize
new modes of transport our
parking provision for bicycles
sorry i'm being interrupted madam
chairman i can't
right i think the microphone's turned
off now okay thank you
sorry about that mr young
we made a commitment through the climate
change
to start providing facilities for
electric vehicle charging
whether they be electric bikes or
whether they be electric cars
but also for ordinary pedal bikes we are
very
very we have a very very poor provision
for these
services in our car parks and we need
to get that done and we need to do it
now not in five to ten years
we need to do it now thank you
thank you councilman
uh can i just ask um councillors who
have already spoken
um from the that they're mostly from the
sudbury
uh area to take off their hands up sign
please there are four councillors with
their hands up and i think it's going to
cause confusion later on
you put down your hands please
um madame chairman it's councillor
mayberry here mine is definitely down
girls is down it's um councillor airs
barrett croswell and owen
please could you put your hands down
thank you my mine is down as well
mine's down too mine's done madam
chairman i think i think i've worked out
why
my hand keeps going up because uh alison
owen has
the same initials and i think that's
possibly where we've
had our problems with the hand going up
and down okay
okay thank you councillor airs let's go
see you now
so we'll return to the meeting now um
thank you
i would now like to invite hadley north
ward member
councillor dawson to respond to the
petition
um you have up to three minutes to
um to speak councillor dawson uh thank
you madam chair
um i'd also like to take this off to you
thanking the hadley residents for
bringing this
forward this petition
can you hear me can you hear me
catherine yes i can sorry
yes i can sorry counselor thank you we
can start again i just like thank you
for bringing forward this position i
should like to start by clarifying i
fully understand and realize there's a
need to balance the beijing's budget
but to introduce these hard-hitting
parking tariffs hidden in the budget is
not really now the time and i'm pleased
that the petition
has been brought forward by hadley to
highlight this
i'm at the firm position that any
decision that affects so many businesses
and people
should be assessed following proper
consultation
as discussed by roger and that's
understanding of the local issues rather
than
um how this has come about i fully
support the petition and thank those
for all the signatures but it was very
evident yesterday
at the ovu scrutiny committee which i
sit on i was left with a number of
questions that were left unanswered or
not properly addressed in this report
over the parking recommendations which
this
petition is objecting to and they
so i'll outline a few of them briefly
which was
why was there no proper consultation
with the stakeholders i.e the local
businesses shoppers or residents at this
point in time
why was there no communication with
county councillors
local district councillors hadley town
council or even our mayor
the decision of this proposal seem to be
based
apparently on a low impact point in
sudbury
in february when the weather conditions
would have automatically reduced the
time spent by shoppers
and this figure was used as the basis
for the 16-foot or minute average stay
of a shopper in a town the information
provided was based on a snapshot
study in sudbury and i think you know my
previous experience in lloyd's london
and twenty years we don't do snapshot
studies and we certainly don't do things
based on evidence on informal in
observations which was another point
that came out
and there was also which had been
mentioned previously by i believe the
leader
um although this what it wasn't brought
up yesterday there was no evidence or
analysis provided of the algorithms that
had been used
and they're no mention at all regarding
the displacement of
cars to side streets the environmental
damage and the generation of further
carbon emissions
which it were meant to be reducing and
most importantly the effect on our local
economy in hadley
i think i've got three minutes i wanted
to sum up
councillor beer and i requested last
year
a comprehensive parking strategy review
of parking over a year ago
today neither of us have been consulted
either directly or indirectly
only to find this parking proposal of
increased tariffs was slipped into the
annual budget prior to the review which
is to take place
later this year i believe uh i have to
say that it is every
inec timing for such a proposal to be
brought
for environment it appears the proposal
was pushed forward by
officers to plug the 45 000 debt in
hadley which quite frankly in the big
picture could be easy
thank you thank you councillor dawson
thank you
i would like now to um invite
the the councillor for hadley south
councillor fraser to respond to the
petition you have
up to three minutes yeah
thank you madam chairman um some of the
points in mind were
uh have been covered already so i won't
go over um
the same ground so it might just be a
little bit shorter but um
this petition um and i thank steve lang
for raising it and for all the
residents in hadley for signing it
[Music]
it's just more essential than ever
because we need to maintain the vitality
of our high street it's the unique
selling point of our town
stephen lang he's the local businessman
he's raised this
petition four weeks ago and in quick
time it raised over 1300 signatures so
that just
shows the strength of feeling over this
issue and when you
examine that um this petition isn't
calling for just the continuance of a
convenient
free service for the residents but the
towns
people the residents in hadley are very
concerned over the
survival of the economy of the attack of
the town itself
okay and that includes mostly you know
the high street businesses who are the
very
beating heart of this town and i'm
afraid actually the way this
baby actually passed this report over
was very poorly communicated over
and that's why it hasn't been received
well
the two points from the e-petition are
that um
new outlets have recently opened and
they could
have a severe impact on their businesses
but also for the establishment
establishment as well established ones
as well
and i think it's all agreed it's been uh
highlighted by
uh the mayor frank mintz that we
want to have a full consultation
involved involving the town
the council the chamber of commerce the
businesses and we need that extra time
so i do
agree that this consultation should be
delayed
until we have a full um impact statement
of what has happened
to the businesses as they emerge from
covid
i'll give you an example of the effect
um that
um a policy like this could have
last year um the safer placer places
measures were installed along the high
streets now during this time i've been
speaking with the
businesses asking them how it how those
that measures
affected them uh and they said certainly
once the measures were in place their
footfall and income dropped
significantly so we have
imperial empirical data that those sort
of
badly thought through policies which
haven't had full consultation
and research do cause a big problem
um and i spend all my money in the town
i go around the businesses frequently
and i ask the um the shop owners how
things are going and how this
car parking proposal will affect them
and they all say unanimously it's not
going to happen 30 seconds
okay thank you very much so um all i'll
wind up there saying i will support this
petition uh we do need a great more
consultation
involving the retailers the businesses
and the town council
thank you thank you councillor fraser
i would now like to take the opportunity
to respond to the petition myself
as a hadley ward member i would like to
emphasize
that the words i'm about to say are not
spoken
in my role as chairman but specifically
in my capacity
as ward counsellor
i and the whole town fully support the
petition to retain
free parking in hadley my ward
hadley south will be most affected by
the proposed changes
our independent high street is the heart
of our town
this parking fee decision is being made
purely for economic reasons
to support baber's budget with no regard
to the economic health of hadley
and yet the parking deficit for hadley
is only forty five thousand
i welcome a bit more democracy and i
support the petitions call for
consultation
local members were not consulted i do
not support any change to short-term
parking fees
as once the principal is broken it is
the easy target for future erosion
but i recognize the mood in the council
the rethink parking on the high street
report
said each high street should be examined
individually
hadley's almost full high street against
trend
can be attributed to free parking
while other authorities are ceasing
parking charges
faber is introducing them
we are currently experiencing our third
lockdown it's the worst time to
introduce
yet another barrier to recovery last
week little grey bird announced its
closure
and others may follow businesses need
time to recover some are operating on
slim margins anyway
by july we may only just be out of
lockdown
january and february is the time when
hospitality and shops face their hardest
time of year
the earliest i find acceptable if change
is necessary
is april 2022 or after the parking
strategy
review the report states the average
length of stay
is 64 minutes to offer just half an hour
free is unworkable
and an hour is not enough either older
people and families can take a long time
to organize themselves and reach the
shops
people can use the range next etc and
ipswich for free
when lockdowns are lifted users need to
be encouraged to leave their home
and use our town stay as long as
possible
not dissuaded the report talks about
churn china's only an issue on saturday
mornings
no ticket saturday pm is replaced with
charges one pound may not be large for
some
for others it is two pints of milk and a
loaf of bread
the shortest free time i find acceptable
is two hours
finally parking fees for hadley should
be lower than sudbury
with its bigger offer of gainsborough
house more shops
a station a decent bus service
investing hadley should be backing
hadley businesses
hadley people did not complain too much
when baber moved its office from cork's
lane
but cabinet are hitting the town again
with something they do
feel very strongly about removing three
hours
free parking thank you
i would now like to invite councillor
malveezy
to respond to the petitioner
thank you very much madam chairman
the position the petition asks that we
maintain
free parking in hadley car parks
i believe it is truer to refer to the
parking in our car parks as
subsidised parking there are many costs
maintaining a car park as evidenced by
the hadley walk
car park which is in desperate need of
refurbishment
but keeps being pushed down the
financial priority list
as i highlighted yesterday at overview
and scrutiny and
they also highlighted that this is a
discretionary service
and not a statutory service the current
report prepared for cabinet in seventh
or for the 7th of january will not be
the report that goes to cabinet in
february
because we are listening to overview and
scrutiny
to hadley town council to sudbury
chamber of commerce
sudbury town center manager and the
likes cabinet also
deliberately deferred any consideration
of the proposals in january so that it
could be considered by overview and
scrutiny first
and in order to be able to debate the
petition from hadley tonight
at this juncture i'd like to thank
councillor mcgraw for his skillful and
impartial chairmanship
of yesterday's meeting we have heard the
os's
committee recommendation with regard to
one hour free parking
and the cabinet report and proposals
will be rewritten to take into account
the debate tonight
this all started with a visit to hadley
railway walk which as i've said earlier
is in a sorry straight
that may be look at the other car parks
in baber and hadley
generally they are they all need
upgrading
spaces are too tight for today's larger
cars side
signage is poor or inadequate
in our commitment to climate change we
committed to alternative but sustainable
modes of transport
bike parks electric vehicle charging
points all
desperately needed to deliver these
objectives
change is also needed i ran the only mba
in retailing and wholesaling
at the institute for retail studies at
stirling university
and was also one of the first graduate
intakes to marx and spencer's
people do not drive to a town simply to
park free
they drive to a town that offers what
they're looking for the retail mix and
offer in hadley
is very different to sudbury hadley gets
used by its shoppers who shop every
couple of days
two book butchers an award-winning
delicatessen
and a new green grocer deli are all
short
shelf life items also it's instant
personalized and not chain store driven
which suggests
they're less likely to shop online
a town center review about to be
published by the institute for retail
studies and also bill grimsey's
acclaimed review bill grimsey was former
iceland ceo
and he's done a review into the future
of high street both they both recognize
that our town centers need to be greener
have more shared space and must offer
facilities for alternative transport
modes
the claim that free parking will bring
people into shop is a fallacy
people will travel if the offering is
what they want marx and spencer's in
is an anchor store in most towns but
they left sudbury
because of diminishing footfall which
confirms my earlier statement that free
parking does not bring shoppers into
town
hadley has a lot to offer the tourist
sector jane t
snowden has worked tirelessly to promote
benton end in hadley
i believe that a revised policy is
needed a policy that moves our carping
car parking provision into the 21st
century
that enables car parking to be a
financially self-sufficient service
that provides a revenues through stream
which will enable us to move to more
sustainable travel
to encourage residents and visitors to
use the appropriate car park
any revenue stream cannot be spent on
anything other than
needs associated with car parking
we are moving to a greener way of living
and therefore we need to move away from
the approach to parking
that may have worked in the 70s or the
eighties
but no longer does today it's time for
us to be brave
and have the courage of our convictions
and i thank you very much
thank you councillor malzizi as you
heard we
had a an overview and scrutiny committee
meeting yesterday so i'm going to invite
the chair of overview and scrutiny
committee to speak now
thank you mr councillor mccraw thank you
very much madam chair
um i'd like to refer anybody involved to
the um agenda supplement the tabled
papers
which contain the draft minute from
yesterday's overview and scrutiny
meeting on this report
and perhaps before i do so before you
have a chance to go through all those
i'd like to just describe the role of
scrutiny in this and all matters
our job is to consider matters perhaps
in more detail than would normally
be available to either a cabinet or even
and particularly a council
we systematically examine the reports
and evidence that are put before us
we can bring out more but there is a
limit to what we can bring out we must
examine
the report in front of us and scrutinize
it properly
a great deal more information was
available and was able to be discussed
even in the lengthy meeting yesterday
we are not decision makers in this role
we can make recommendations to the
appropriate decision-making
body whether that be cabinet in this
case or council
in others i'm here to report then on the
content of that meeting i believe the
minutes
describe enough information to explain
the nature of the debate
and how much consideration was given and
i think the important point is that we
came to
some recommendations in the interests
of transparency
and because the votes were close both
the uh amended proposal and the
substantive proposal that was eventually
recommended to cabinet
have been included i'd just like to
point out
that the differences between those two
are a matter of timing one uh
states that the free parking exists for
two hours
the other for one hour both cabinet and
you have this in front of you and i'm
sure cabinet will
take both into account when making their
decision
the other one is concerning
implementation and on the matter of
implementation
it was specifically asked if the
review was capable of being carried out
within the time frame
where need existed the review
a full review a substantial body perhaps
to last five or ten years
is a process that will take 18 months
simply put
it does not appear we have 18 months
the situation as it exists needs to be
addressed rather sooner
and tabling it for not one but two
budgets would be a mistake in my
personal view
so you have the recommendations in front
of you those presented to cabinet are
only changed in
the two matters i've referred to i won't
be commenting any further in this matter
i believe that the
overview and scrutiny committee did
their job and
i commend their report to you and to the
cabinet
thank you
thank you council macro so now we will
move to
the debate counselors will only be
allowed to speak
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
and if councillors could please remember
that we are debating
the petition not the whole matter about
parking in as a principal
so um if we would if councils would like
to open the debate
uh we can do so now council award
um i believe you wanted to speak
to the in the debate thank you mr
chairman thank you
i'd first like to say that i don't
really see this petition's purpose
it requests that free parking is
retained in all hadley car parks
but our proposal doesn't get rid of it
it simply reduces it
and many of the responses we have
received except that this is a sensible
and necessary thing to do
but with concerns about the specific
details
we're having to make difficult decisions
to ensure that our finances are secure
in the medium term
and none is more difficult or
contentious than this one
we are no longer able to justify the
subsidy that so-called free parking
requires
particularly as this burden falls on all
our residents whether they use the car
parts or not
we need to free up the money we are
diverting to the upkeep of our car parts
for other things
for mostly balancing our budget in an
era where government is cutting our
support and expects us to be
self-reliant financially
i know that many have made the assertion
that this will harm the high street
businesses
indeed this is implied in today's
petition but there is no evidence from
anywhere in the country that parking
charges affect football
as councilor malvisi has so passionately
articulated
towns thrive will die on the offer they
provide not parking charges
and councillor marve is a retail expert
unlike the facebook warriors
some have argued against charging to use
car parks because all our services
should be
covered by council tax and business
rates unfortunately
these simply cannot we're never able to
pay for everything we do which is why we
used to get substantial support from the
government
now we must look to other ways of
raising income as well as making
efficiency improvements and cutting
costs
one way is to charge for discretionary
services and the principle of the user
pace is already established as a way of
providing
these we do it for garden waste
collection and indeed
long-term parking and the moral case for
this is clear
people should not expect things that we
don't need
to provide to be free at the point of
use and for others to share the burden
of paying for
them from feedback we have received
the principal concerns are the length of
free parking and the timing of the
changes
while there may still be restrictions on
movement these concerns were echoed in
the debate at hadley town council last
week
it was never the intention of
introducing this until a pandemic was in
permanent decline
hence our proposed july start date the
recent very serious resurgence
exacerbated by the new variant will
delay recovery this year
because of this we were already
considering a review of the start date
yesterday overview and scrutiny
recommended a delay
to the third quarter next year and they
thought that the 1r3 period
also suggested by the sudbury chamber of
commerce the sudbury town centre manager
and several hadley town councillors last
week would be more sensible
having heard these views cabinet is
actually minded to agree
i hope members today accept that these
are reasonable compromises for a way
forward
finally it is clear from overview and
scrutiny yesterday and the question
earlier that there is a confusion about
the long-term parking strategy we will
be undertaking
this will look forward and focus on
interventions relating to things like
support for the plans coming out of our
visioning work
and how future capacity can support the
planned population growth
this paper is not dependent on that the
cabinet welcomes comments from council
today
thank you madam chairman thank you
council award
so now i'll open it up um to other
councillors
uh councillor adrian osborne did you
want to speak
your hand is raised uh yeah thank you
madam chairman it
it basically um just uh first of all can
i just say that
the chairman uh counselor allison mccraw
was
really impartial in his in his way of
chairing a meeting
and he should be credited with a good
meet a very difficult meeting done well
uh as a baba district councillor
as well as sudbury town council i do
understand concerns that have been
raised
and uh having been at the ons meeting on
monday i will be consistent with my
comments
however uh the council must deliver an
approved balanced budget for 2122
to ensure and this is my main concern
that any continuation of our essential
services
for our communities are driven forward
by uh monies as uh councillor
malovey has already said i have seen
both
emails both against and for the proposal
from this i feel that a longer period
than the proposed half an hour would be
acceptable but not to continue with the
current three hours
also i'd like to see the implementation
date for the revised charge
to be made for the late for late 20 20
21
or early 2022 and has already been
alluded to by councillor uh mccraw
this has now gone forward for cabinet
decision
difficult decisions is a big part of
being a councillor and it's important
that we
base our decisions on the facts and not
rather than the assumptions many
residents in sudbury and hadley have
real problems with parking near where
they live
although not part of this discussion it
does impact on our car parks
i would like to see a review be
undertaken to
to find solutions including residence
parking permits
in our car parks uh and that would i
think would be a great
uh a great incentive for our um
residents that have unfortunately uh
have uh
houses that cannot have parking directly
up their drives
in fact uh almost the area within
um uh within sudbury which is
very much like that and i have been
experienced quite a lot of
emails concerning this so um with
councillor mulvaisy
i hope that she will look at that along
with the other things and i must say
council melvais's comments and
ways that she operated the uh this
discussion
was excellent thank you
thank you councillor osborne have i got
any other people who would like to
take part in the debate
councillor beer thank you madam chairman
um my motion of the 22nd of october
called for the council
to review park and provisions in sudbury
headley other areas of babur
and identify what extra capacity might
be needed to cover any loss of car
parking spaces
this also included talking and working
together with our partners
subpretend council hadley town council
suffolk county council and also parishes
the the members also had the opportunity
to get involved
and we i also called on the public to
come up with suggestions and solutions
as how the council
should go forward on this issue we
asked for a group to be set up and we're
still waiting
many members already commented on a lot
of that
um the other point i want to follow is
that we now have a petition collected by
thomas merrell of sudbury with a hund
1662 plus signatures
i know it's been ruled out of order but
that is a significant number of people
who
who signed a petition and a lot of those
come from my area
according to a survey in sudbury from
the sudbury steering
group committee 59 percent of people who
responded in their survey
uh came outside the sudbury boundary so
i'm assuming
59 come from areas around the suburb
boundary
great coronard is part of that and i
have to say
that i have residents and people uh
in great corner who support the trades
people of sudbury
and they in return rely on us to
continue shopping and supporting
activities in sudbury
increases in car parking charges and
removal
parking space in town center means you
will charge more
and take away spaces so that the motors
will get less for more
all this will have a disastrous effect
on the town traders
and shopkeepers of sudbury we have many
empty shops in our towns
and just recently lost three outlets
with one major supplier on the market
hill
and a major outlet in north street plus
the loss of
full and part-time jobs which follows
this
and will continue if we carry on hitting
the motors with high
increased car parking charges and
cutting the free period
we do need to provide more disabled and
improve taxi ranks and bus stops but we
also need to provide
for boaters to stop shot and go
this if we increase car punches this
will not help the environment only make
matters worse because cars will be
driving down the town trying to find
places to park clogging up side roads to
park
without having to pay local residents
will lose parking spaces in front of the
property and will cause more problems
so those wishing to reduce car usage
should realize that three to 13 mile
rain trip to sudbury by the closest
villages of sudbury is easily replaced
by a 30 to 40 mile
visit to one of the larger towns
circular suburban where there's more to
us your time is out
so disgrace thank you your time is up
councillor beer
thank you um have i got any other people
who
like to take part in the debate
counselor owen
yes please thank you right thank you um
yeah totally agree with them peter um
i appreciate that um councillors are
faced with having a
to balance the books in a very difficult
financial climate
and we are the unp presidential
circumstances that we are facing at this
time
we are aware that the baby citizens have
enjoyed free parking for many years
which has helped maintain the football
in our two
towns and sudbury in particular has
bucked the national trend
in shop closures with only eight closure
up
as against the national trend of 13 we
believe that this
is part is due of the employment of our
town centre manager who is doing an
excellent job in
revitalizing our town but also the
benefit of free parking for the first
three hours
for for all our visitors if parking
charges were to be introduced
our belief is that we it could it would
have too far reaching negative impact on
the retailers as a result of
of an anticipated drop in the footfall
of a normal time subway benefits from
higher number of visitors than most
other towns of comparable sizes in
suffolk we certainly make visitors
welcome and are considered
a very sociable place to visit on most
of
of most of the days of the week in the
introduction of car parking charging
would seriously damage our ability to
maintain that position we cannot offer
the larger and cheaper outlets that
are available in the larger towns that
surround us
our main attractions is free car parking
and social tolerance
if you take that away then what is left
charging always starts low very low and
becomes
more of a revenue raise of the longer it
remains
lose your shops lower employment more
families on benefit less
business rates collected lower labor
income
sorry thank you thank you councillor
owen
and sorry i've got i've got different
things on different ones
did you have some more to say yes please
if you don't mind yes
bit more time the reducer congestion
at what point on by how much improve air
quality at what point
by how much fewer cars to park
if so how many we haven't had nothing
back we haven't had
anything back anything anything that
states this
on how we do so i believe we haven't had
nothing back
on it so yeah
sorry and i'm sorry i didn't realize my
camera wasn't on
yeah no that that'll be i just got all
confused there
fine no that's fine thank you councillor
owen
is there anyone else that would like to
take part in the debate
councillor fraser
thank you once again madam chairman um
there's been a lot of talk in this
debate so far and uh really about the
the report but i think we're losing
focus on really
um what had what it's going to do to
hadley or what it could possibly do it
could cause significant damage
to the economy here we have a fragile
high street
and businesses have been badly hit by
the pandemic and we soon to lose one of
our largest outlets
the current three hour free parking is a
big draw for visitors to the town and
our
high street is unique in what it
delivers we cannot compare hadley with
other towns such as
sudbury or even lebanon which has been
conveniently
left out of this charges they all have
different qualities comparing hadley
with sudbury's like comparing apples
with potatoes
they're not the same we're not out of
this pandemic yet in fact we're still in
government's tier five
although we can be optimistic now with
the vaccination
and this global pandemic has hit high
streets around the country
massively impacting footfall and with
reduced revenues for independent
retailers that were uniquely well
represented here in hadley
although the introduction of these fees
is scheduled for the first of july
um or now or with the scrutiny committee
a little bit later i suggest they
shouldn't be um
there should be no change to our car
parking arrangements
until we've had a post kovic kovid
impact assessment of the our high street
itself
there's no urgent rush to bring these
changes in
and if i can just remind baber we're
here to support business not to
dens it i'm relieved that the scrut
overview and risk scrutiny committee
have recommended changes
however i don't feel the one hour period
is enough
i don't think we should have the same
level of charges as sodberry as i've
mentioned before also
the reason for this is have a look at
the geography has anyone from baber
actually come and re
carried out reconnaissance within hadley
there is actually
a fair amount of on-street parking
available and to
put in charges we'll encourage uh
motorists to look for parking elsewhere
and then you will have a build-up of
congestion with associated pollution
in our side roads and high street and
that just totally totally goes against
one of the principles here that is going
to uh this
report was going to encourage a shifting
change of behavior
towards a more sustainable travel
meeting the climate change ambitions i
don't agree that it will achieve that
consultation consultation okay
thank you madam chairman consultation
must
take place and if we can engage with the
businesses they can engage a little bit
of ownership of it and they'll come out
they could come out some wonderful ideas
um refunding parking fees for spending x
amount of pounds
and that sort of thing so i'll reiterate
again i do support this petition
thank you thank you councillor fraser
councillor barrett
councillor barrett yes i'm i'm just here
thank you
inviting me to speak um i'm very pleased
to hear that cabinet are listening um
thank you for that
um i had prepared to speak uh this
evening
because i i was expecting it to be a
full debate
so i'm disappointed in its only uh
uh debate on the the petition uh not as
i had expected
um what i'd like to say is um that a
change
a change to to reduce free parking must
be carefully considered
to anticipate any adverse uh
consequences that could
um that could fall retailers and
hospitality
sector have had a battering not just
from covid and
recent months but the out-of-town
developments
um the internet shopping um this is
hardly the time
to deter shoppers from using our town
centers and
supporting our retail um so the
justification
you would you would assume that that was
um
sufficient um to even consider such a
damaging move with our
our um high street hanging on a thread
um i don't i don't believe the the
justification is there
we have found uh more money in the
budget than we'd anticipated this year
um and certainly for for now there is a
stay of
execution i believe until we can at
least complete this um period of
um covid and um show some support for
our
our um ailing retailers
um in sudbury we are bucking the trend
retaining high street banks
unfortunately hadley i believe you've
not been so lucky
um and we've we've seen removal of
parking spaces already on market hill
that's affecting
um those um just wanting to pop to the
bank
um or carrying heavy you know heavy
amounts to
to um to deposit and that has already
dampened footfall um
i i i don't believe that um
we have conducted a sufficient economic
impact assessment
to fully understand the consequences of
this um
this measure um we're i'm you know
advised that the um the amounts are
insignificant
and um that's that's us assume that that
is so insignificant that it doesn't
deter
shoppers from um paying their their
money and and
paying for parking um
thank you um but i i believe
even even a small charge does um
influence behavior and there is a
certainly a thing called resistance to
to paying
um that needs to be anticipated as to
how much
actual income we would see i do not
think it is justified
thank you thank you councillor barrett
councillor lindsay and can i just remind
all councillors that we are talking to
the petition
councillor lindsay would you like to
speak to the debate
thank you thank you chair um
yes i just start off quickly by um
a point of clarification on councillor
peter beer's remarks some of which i
agreed with um uh it is frustrating that
we haven't really had progress on that
car parking review
but the final motion that the council
agreed although
council appears correct that his
original motion asked for
an examination or an increase in
capacity in car parking capacity
that was amended by by me
and uh and some others and that was
unanimously agreed
but that so the amendment was to examine
what
level of car parking capacity
would be appropriate and that's
really important difference because
actually
we've undertaken as a council to reduce
our carbon emissions to zero by 2030
and and the the work that's already been
done along that
um particularly at the county level by
officers across the county
this states that we need to reduce car
use by 25
to get to that goal by 25 by by
so we do actually need to reduce car
parking
uh not increasing uh and and the only
way we can do that
and still get people to town uh
is by investing in sustainable travel um
so but this so i support the principle
of charging for car parking
unfortunately this
the report that was originally before
cabinet
and that went to scrutiny um is just
aimed at really
filling this year's um budget gap
um that's what it's for it's fulfilling
the gap in the budget
and there's a token effort at saying
one of the recommendations is for a
proportion
of funding to be um set aside for
sustainable travel
um and but the charging is going to be
implemented
straight away and and frankly that's
i've always said
that if we're going to start charging
for parking we have to be crystal clear
how much money we're going to invest in
the alternatives which is walking
cycling bus and and
how much and what the timetable is and
this this
these proposals aren't clear on that
whatsoever
um
okay i think it's important also to say
that
just on the principle of charging we
must remember that
uh by the last time i checked five
percent of households
in rural areas of babur have no access
to a car that's in rural areas so in
villages like mine
in billiston there are a proportion of
people who do not have a private car
and they're dependent on public
transport why should
all us ratepayers subsidize people
for parking um i believe that people
who want to use the services that cost
money
to park should have to pay for them it's
just the case the time is up
and making sure the money goes to the
right place thank you thank you
councillor lindsay
councillor jameson
thank you chair um i can't add um
more than many councillors already said
uh regarding the potential effects
this this proposal will have on our
local businesses
at this current time um it could be
devastating it may not
and a lack of consultation has been key
if we'd read
proper consultation with hadley and
sudbury town councils
early on perhaps um issues like that
would have been brought to light
um so i cannot add more reads to what's
already been said but
i would like to mention that a key
common perm driver for this
proposal is to increase churn or in key
increase cars going in and out of our
local towns
this flies in the face of accounts of
the cabinet saying that this is um or
referring to this as being an
improvement for environmental purposes
if we're going to encourage more people
to drive into town
how is that going to uh reduce our
carbon impact
i mean council mel beezy
put forward the motion for a car climate
emergency last year and yet now she's
trying to get more people to drive
in and out of our towns and why is there
no
um benefits for people driving electric
vehicles perhaps they could have free
parking if we're going
to introduce a charge i think
this proposal needs to be
put back and amended as part of a wider
transport strategy in line with the
parking proposal park
car parking strategy that he's drew out
at some point so um
he's i think it's uh being brought
forward at the wrong time and it's
too early okay
thank you councillor jameson councillor
airs
thank you chair and yes it's just that
um
i'm concerned about this footfall
because i've been doing some
maths analysis you know i love maths and
59
of um the people that come in
shopping are from out of the area so
they're not
all hadley um residents
so you do have a lot of people because
they love the town
who actually go in and visit so um
footfall is an important thing to and
remember we must preserve hadley it's a
wonderful town
and we need at least two hours um for
parking
because of the queues covered people are
queueing
you know this is these are desperate
times and
this is at the wrong time and i really
do feel that we should support hadley
as much as we can thank you chairman
thank you councillors councillor
mayberry
thank you thank you very much chairman
a lot a lot has been said um that
i had been thinking of over the the past
few days while
whilst thinking about uh car parking
and if i refer to the the petition there
was a reply from council of um
councillor fraser um about lavanam why
was lavenham not included
it is interesting that the the policy
and i'm just moving um from the petition
for a short
moment the policy actually states town
center car parks but apparently
is covering all car parks within baby
lavanam have long tried the parish
council that is have long tried
to have take ownership or responsibility
of their car parks
they know how to deal with the tourists
and that
is what they wish to do and that is why
lavenham is not being
specifically mentioned council appraiser
i also have concerns when
the cabinet member talks about
residents shouldn't subsidize car
parking
and she was talking about discretionary
and statutory
um projects that are available within
baber
it has to be remembered that there are
many statutory as well as discretionary
projects
that many residents would not like to
support
besides car park charges
and so i think that is a false
declaration to state
that um we shouldn't be subsidizing
something
that all residents do not use because it
is the same for many
items i could list them but i don't have
enough time
i am most concerned with the petition
that there has been no mention of any
possible annual increases if car parking
charges
are introduced i have long stated to
those who will listen that if car
parking charges
are put into place then there should be
a period of time
when there are no annual increases
planned
and i'm talking a minimum of three years
but more
like five i still maintain
that this is the wrong time to bring in
any discussion on car
park charges for anyone within baber
we are all trying to survive kovid
we are all trying to recover from covet
we're all trying to
plan for the future thank you
i would just like to say that my other
concern
is that i have been told the fees would
be ring fenced
for car parking only thank you
thank you councillor mayberry councillor
creswell
thank you chair first of all what i'd
like to say
is i i think sudbury and hadley although
they're different
i think we're both in it together we
both got our own agendas but we've got
they've got similar
problem and i think we should i don't
know it's the word stick together but
not be divisive and and and
one's got this and one's got that and i
think we should be working together
we both got an issue with the parking
chargers
for different reasons now when the
survey was done in february
uh a bad time to do any type of survey
um
in a car park um it's much different in
july isn't it we all know that people
like to come out in the sunshine
and also in suffering there's no parking
charges from 12 o'clock
lunchtime through till monday morning
and then you get a lot of families
coming to subway because of that
and they spent time they might go down
to the craft to the booty spot
wander around town buy little things go
to a cafe
go out to a pub for a meal and i think
that'll have a detrimental effect
now as as for like allison said
at the moment sudbury has got eight
percent premises
vacancy and national average i believe
is fourteen percent not thirteen but
it's a major and i believe part of that
is because the parking is free
and i believe people come into sudbury i
certainly believe
people coming from the villages like
clemsford which is
probably halfway between sudbury and
berries and edmonds
if there's parking charges here i
certainly would be going to bury some
edmonds because
not being rude there's not a great deal
of shops it's certainly not
close shops there's nothing here for men
really we've just seen
the market he'll shut off and we've just
said i know
the market's changed but we've seen
winch and blacks go
we're going to see people like peacocks
leave
and sudbury is struggling like all towns
like hadley probably
is under the same kind of pressure so
my view is we shouldn't be having
parking charges
certainly not in the present climate i i
think it's the wrong thing at the wrong
time
and my view is we should keep it how it
is for the time being
i understand the cabinet have
we have a money issue and this isn't the
green this isn't about green this isn't
about
let's get infrastructure and for
transport let's get people in from the
villages
i would i would say robert was asked and
he wanted to get to sudbury to do a bit
of shopping
he's agreeing he would drive into sub
because there's no links
the cert the bus service 30 seconds the
bus services are poor
and if you live in sudbury you probably
can't get out of sudbury after 7 pm
unless you've got a car
and you can't get into subway unless
you've got a car so
my view is until you do something
strategic work it out and do it properly
keep it how it is
thank you very much and i support hadley
as well thank you
thank you councillor crosswell
councillor dawson
yes sorry i was just wondering whether
at this point
um where there's anyone else that wants
to speak whether we perhaps might
ought to move to a vote on the petition
would it could i put forward
that now yes you can there is one person
more to speak but yes you can
um would you like to allow them to go
forward then before me
yes so then i'll come back to you
councillor dawson thank you
uh councillor carpendale
thank you chairman um
i'm pleased very pleased to hear uh from
councillors malveezy and ward that
things are likely to be very different
when this report goes back to cabinet
and that they are likely to make some
very different recommendations
about the the timing and the and the
costs
uh can i say that um i do sympathize
with the concerns that are being raised
uh in the hadley position
um they're raising some very obvious
fears i think about what might happen
uh in in terms of the impact on the high
street but the reality
and the impact of course are unknowns at
the moment
um so we can't really make a judgment on
that because we don't have the facts
before us
uh with respect to the free parking
it may not bring people into the town
but i do wonder if charges
might put people off going into the town
so i've got some sympathy with that
argument as well
what i would say though is that i
absolutely endorse
the recommendations that have come
through from overview and scrutiny
committee
like a lot of you i probably um spent
this part
three hours listening to that debate
yesterday morning and i think they
raised some very valid arguments
but i do like the recommendations that
have come out
namely one hour's free parking and a
deferred implementation date
um to go across the district not just
hadley but
sudbury as well i do think that now is
the time that residents
and councillors have got to recognize
the the realities present and future
of both costs and financing even though
we always have the desire to try to
support our
our market towns and their economies
i do think it's a pity that this item
has surfaced ahead of a comprehensive
parking review
because it it's certainly putting the
cart before the horse
and it lacks a transport strategy
which should be genuinely integrated
with our environmental aims towards
carbon reduction in the district
i have to say also that i think it's
unfortunate the handling
of this whole matter hasn't exactly
brought us favorable headlines
and i hope that the entire process
including the lack of local consultation
the lack of involvement
with with local businesses local members
even
i hope that process itself will be
reviewed and noted for any future
contentious issues so those are my
comments madam chairman
thank you thank you councillor carpenter
um
i also have councillor plum wanting to
speak
councillor plum would you like to say a
few words before
we consider going to a vote yes please
chair thank you
i'm i'm just sitting here listening to
the debate
and i'm i've listened to margaret made
councillor mayberry
mentioning lavaland may i leave the
thought in the council's mind wasn't
hadley and sudbury
consider taking over the car parking
themselves
or even if they can't manage that it's
coming halfway
to meet the district council let's say
we're talking about one hour
if padley or feels it's got to be two
will the town council subsidize that
second hour
just some thoughts thank you councillor
plum
so i think we're coming towards the end
of our debate now
um i think we'll return to
councillor dawson uh i believe you wish
to
move of motion yeah i'd like to say
really having listened to everything
this evening
i think the bottom line is that this
proposal has not involved any
consultation with the local state
stakeholders
and that's why i'd like to move and
propose that
fellow members support this petition
brought forward by residents and those
from sudbury that regressively were
rejected
and this position is respected
and that the decision is deferred and
assessed until after the comprehensive
part and strategy review has been
completed and not before
um i'm being advised that's not possible
to have
a um a vote
covering those topics we are actually
having to vote for
the either for or against
the potential to simplify it then i i
would urge all
members now this evening to support this
and respect
what is being asked of us so can i
confirm that you are voting
to support the petition yes
thank you councillor dawson uh have we
got the second
please uh yes is
do is that counselor beer yes
thank you council beer you want to
support the um
motion to support sorry you want to
second
the motion to support the petition
is that correct
oh sorry counselor i believe you've
muted right
uh yeah yes uh i'm quite happy to do
that i'd like to go further but i know
you'd have to rule me out of order sorry
thank you very much thank you councillor
beer
so in that case councillors i believe we
have come to the end i think most people
have had the opportunity
to speak who wanted to um
unless i unless there's anyone who um
feels a desperate need to speak who has
not had the opportunity
to do so can i ask for a recorded vote
if that's all right well your vote in
effect is recorded
anyway because um
we have an electronic vote now yeah can
we have it recorded in the minute okay
we need
five or we can have five people
if there are four other people who
um wish to also uh
ask for a recorded vote in that case we
could do
are there that other people coming
forward in fact
just about everyone's got a hand up but
i don't know whether their old hands on
you
um chair chairman it's councillor mabry
here i'm very happy to support
councillor owen on that subject
and i need three others please uh yes
madam chairman i'll support it quite
often when we have this car parking
debate we have a recorded phone
okay and my house as well is that
councillors
yes and i think we do we need one more
i've lost count now
we need one more is there one more
person who who
wishes to support that yes councillor
croswell
okay thank you so we will now have a
recorded vote
um so do have an electronic vote under
recorded vote is that how it works
so so councillors we are going to have
a recorded vote and an electronic vote
food
chair could you please make make sure
you know what we're voting for
yes most exactly yes so
first of all let me clarify the voting
structure
because i'm being told different things
so what we're doing
is we're going to have an electronic
vote
no i'm now being told
sorry councillors and um viewers
um the monitoring officer has informed
me that we will have a traditional
roll call vote
and i would just like to remind you
about what we are voting for
or against um we are voting
in support of the petition
and i will read out to you again the
petition just so
you can be reminded about
the wording of the petition
it was titled free parking hadley
we the undersigned petition the council
to maintain the free parking in all
hadley car parks
it is now more essential than ever for
the vitality and future of hadley heist
creek
to enable local and visiting shoppers to
park free of charge
a number of new outlets have only just
opened and to impinge businesses
sustainability by the introduction of
parking charges
would be completely retrograde any
decisions of this nature
should only take place after the fullest
public
consultation so those are the words
of the petition and we will now carry
out
a roll call or recorded vote
over thank you chair councillors if you
could
um say for against or abstain
thank you councillor arty against
councillor ayers four councillor barrett
four councillor beer four
councillor busby four cancer carpendale
against cancer creswell four
cancer davis abstain cancer dawson
councillor fraser poor
oh sorry she's absent counselor granger
howard
four councillor grandin four
councillor hardacre against
cancer holt against councillor haran
four council jameson or
councillor lindsay against
councillor malveezy
against councillor jan osborne
against councillor owen for
councillor parker abstain
councillor plum against council award
against thank you chair i'll come back
with
the results in a second
councillors um we're just going to have
a 10 minute break
um we've had uh quite a lively debate
and while we um
check on the voting just now
we'll do that and you can have a 10
minute uh comfort break
and we will see you back at
2 25 past 7 please
thank you
oh
welcome back councillors i hope you'll
feel refreshed we are now going to
restart the meeting
and we now have um the result
of the recorded vote
um i'd like to ask our corporate manager
governor
governance and civic office to announce
the vote
the result of the vote thank you chair
the result of the voting was
14 4 14 against
and two abstentions chair would you like
to exercise your casting vote
yes thank you um i would like to
take the opportunity of the
vote casting vote and i would like to
vote
for the motion to support
the petition
thank you chair that is carried thank
you
so as you heard the
notice to that count to um support the
petition is carried
we'll now move on to item seven
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules
all the questions have actually been
dealt with under the petitions item
so there are no further questions
item eight questions by councillors
in accordance with council procedure
rules non-received chair
thank you item nine
paper bc 2018
overview and scrutiny committee report i
would like to invite councillor mccraw
to introduce paper bc 2018
which is for noting councilman crawl
thank you madam chair i'm reporting
today on report number
bc20 stroke 18.
sorry about that almost interrupted
there uh
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee met on the 23rd of november to
discuss the review of outside bodies
these are bodies appointed by the
council at our annual meeting
do not include appointments made by
leaders or the cabinets
uh we went through the me can you hear
me yes sorry
sorry i heard an interruption we um
examined each in turn
using the available evidence uh the
principle was to establish the value
of member representation not only to the
bodies themselves but to the council
to residents and actually many members
felt they got gained
an understanding themselves in the
process
uh a complete record will be found in
the reports and the minutes
um we made a series of recommendations
uh these were
for both baber and mid suffolk according
to different circumstances pertaining to
those
so separate votes were taken on matters
involving
baber and those matters involving
mid-suffolk
the recommendations are listed in the
report
you will see that a number of uh body's
appointments are suggested that they'd
be removed
the reasons for these being either the
no longer the body no longer existing
the lack of relevance or demonstrable
demonstrable value
to the council and in some cases they've
been subsumed by
other bodies on which the council
already had
representation
we also recommended some more specific
things
uh they are contained within them i
don't propose to go through each one
i think the principal ones i would draw
out here would be the fact that we
felt very strongly that support and
training be established for members when
appointed as
representatives to these bodies uh
that has been lacking in the past and we
believe would be very helpful
to members serving in those the
subsequent meeting was held on the 14th
of december and looked at the joint
planning enforcement
the transformation update this has been
a matter of much concern
excuse me councilman crawl yes i'm sorry
to interrupt you counsellor
um but i think you
may be speaking to the wrong paper at
the moment
repeat was repeating to the overview and
scrutiny report that
is on the uh i think you might be
speaking to
item bc 2019
rather than the one that ends 18.
um hang on no sorry um
i'm looking at the report um
from so you
you should be speaking to paper bc
2018 hang on a minute
believe the paper concerning outside
bodies
um comes in at item 2010b
i wasn't aware i had any other reports
to make chair
than the one i'm currently trying to
apparently delivering
you're delivering two papers today
um
that's item 10b i'm just going back in
the agenda but with multiple screens
it's proving to be a little more
difficult
yes uh this is item nine this is item
nine
and you're also um on a 10b
my apologies chair um
i would ask that what i've already
delivered be
taken as read um pages 27 to 30.
um that's okay i'm just getting there
um intervene
i think the report has been repeated
twice
thank you chair and that's the comment i
was just about to make counsellors is
that
there are two items from the chair of
overview and scrutiny on tonight's
agenda
agenda item nine which is report number
bc
2018 that's an overall summary of the
committee's work so it's the usual
chairman's update
and then the first item in that update
review of outside bodies
has also been carried into item 10 on
the agenda and it's
item 10b that relates bc2019
and that's for the council to consider
the recommendations
so councillor mccraw could continue to
give a summary overview on this item
but just remember that the
recommendation
will be considered under item 10. thank
you chad
i apologize chair but i was actually
trying to deliver item 9
which was the summary report rather than
the consideration of the recommendations
in that case it's for me to apologize
my apologies council macro that's all
right i'm
quite easy to get confused in a long
agenda i've been there myself
so uh to return then uh the over
um we're returning back to the outside
bodies at a later point in this meeting
but i thought a useful summary of the
principles adopted
and some specifics i'll return to the
report then
uh of the meeting held on the 14th of
december 2020
which was about the planning enforcement
transformation update
as i say uh planning enforcement and all
matters pertaining to that have been
a bone of some contention i think
uh members will be pleased to hear that
work considerable work has been done
on this the report describes that work
and the nature of it
it's ongoing it is not over and it will
be looked at by overview and scrutiny
in times to come we have already
scheduled another discussion of this
uh later this later next council year
one particular point of information that
might be of help to members specif
specifically is the new enforcement flow
chart
which describes the process from alleged
planning breaches through
to final outcomes and the categorization
and the method of of handling this
so effectively we propose that a joint
member not ember officer task and finish
group be set up
using the experience gained in the joint
local plan member working group
but with possible further input in
conjunction
with political group leaders as i say
this is an ongoing project
and uh and hopefully one that will be
beneficial to both ourselves
and to residents that they can have
confidence in
the effective working of the planning
system i'm happy to take any questions
on the report
either within this meeting or afterwards
thank you councilman mccraw and again i
apologize for any confusion i may have
caused
um are there any questions for cancer
mccraw
councillor dawson have you got your hand
up for for
oh uh counselor owen
have you got your hand up for a question
thank you so i i understand there are no
questions no hands up at the moment
so thank you
no questions of council macro
yes could everyone turn their their
microphones off please if they're not
speaking
um if there are no questions for
councilman
um his paper is for noting and so we'll
then in that case
uh thank you council macro and we'll
move on to the next item
item 10 recommendations from cabinet and
committees
jac stroke 23
half year report on treasury management
2020 to 21.
i would like to invite councillor horan
to introduce
paper jac 23
and move the recommendations on the
agenda
councillor haran thank you very much
madam chairman and um
for ease of um identification this is
um item 10a on the agenda
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months of the financial year
2021 it provides details of performance
effects of decisions taken during that
period
and confirms compliance with the
council's treasury management policy
the report explains in more detail the
factors affecting the strategy
and activities including the regulatory
framework economic conditions
interest rate and liquidity risk
in a relatively short period since the
onset of covert 19 pandemic in march
and the ensuing enforced lockdown in
many jurisdictions
the global economic fallout has been
sharp and
large market reaction was extreme with
large falls in equities
corporate bond markets and to some
extent real estate echoing lockdown
induced paralysis
and the uncharted challenges for
governments businesses and individuals
the employment rate unemployment rate
increased to 4.1 percent
with a further expected peak when the
furlough scheme was due to finish at the
end of october
this was avoided following the revisal
of the scheme
to run to the 31st of march of this year
interest rates remained at the record
low of 0.1 of a percent
and the headline rate of consumer price
inflation
fell to 0.2 percent
more specifically for baby council
banking activities undertaken were
within the daily bank account limits
baba has reduced overall debt by six and
a half million pounds and made
repayments
on long-term public work loan board
loans as well
as repaying short-term local authority
loans
the council has lent a further 1.6
million
to sifco and all investment activities
undertaken were in accordance with the
improved
counterparty list the council's
investment
activities including average returns
can be found at appendix c of the tabled
reports
investment by the council in the funding
circle has reduced
as unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid during the
period this was 48
000 of the 214 000 previously invested
leaving a balance on the 30th september
last year of 166 thousand pounds
i'll finish by saying the council is
compliant with the upper limits for
interest rate exposure
the interest activity undertaken for the
year was done so in priority order of
security and liquidity
over yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy
now the joint audit and standards
committee will be meeting next week
under my chairmanship
on the 25th of january and we'll be
looking at the joint capital investment
and treasury management strategies
we'll also be hoping to examine more
environmental green strategies and
investments
in the next financial year starting in
april
now this paper is for noting and i'm
happy to um
propose it for that looking across my
virtual chamber into my kitchen
that's all i can see but i hope that
somewhere catherine melissa or sue
are at hand to answer any of your
difficult
questions thank you chairman and i look
um
for a second or on this paper thank you
councillor haran
um yes we will need a second in fact we
will be going to a vote on it as well so
it's not just for noting
um so may i have a seconder please
i'd be happy to second that madam
chairman thank you council award
thank you so now we can go to questions
counsellor may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question
may i have any are there any questions
please
counselor lindsay do you have a question
um yes thank you thank you
chairman um i just wondered if
um i'm on i'm actually on the um
audit committee so i um
but since our last meeting i did a
little bit of research into
um i've noted that the public works loan
board
put up the interest rate by one percent
on what we can borrow
um and that has made
there's a fairly new form of borrowing
on the market
um municipal bonds
um which is there's a municipal bond
agency
that we can borrow from which is set up
by the lga
so it's our fellow councils that set
that up not the government
and it's much cheaper than the public
works loan board
so i just wondered if our treasury
management people could
look at the feasibility of borrowing
the future from the municipal
um uh municipal bond
people rather than the public works loan
board thank you
councillor um would you like to answer
that
well i think it's a steer from myself as
chairman i would be driving um
that sort of thing forward yes
definitely um
i'm not too sure if any officer is here
but um
robert is well um welcome to
introduce that next week at the meeting
of his in attendance and yes certainly
yes that we will look at anything thank
you
but i would warn robert there's not um
in the investment side there's not much
out there but from borrowing um
anything we can go you know we think
we'd be grabbed with both hands
i understand catherine steele is here um
catherine is there anything you'd wish
to add
yes thank you thank you madam chairman
yes if i could just
address the council um in relation to
that question
um the pwlb rate has actually come down
again
it was raised by one percent but when
the government announced the changes to
accessing pwlb as part of the
provisional local government finance
settlement
they reduced it again by the 1 so it is
now
back down at a much more competitive
rate
the municipal bond agency is something
that i've looked at
and certainly have talked to our
treasury management advisors
about but there are some strings
attached there is a
joint liability clause in the municipal
bond agency
so that's something we would need to
consider very carefully
before we actually looked at taking any
money from those
thank you thank you
thank you catherine thank you catherine
it just shows so quickly things can
change doesn't it
um is there anyone else that wishes to
ask a question otherwise we can
move to debate any other
any further questions in that case um
we'll now move to debate would anyone
like to open the debate
so i believe no one wishes to
enter the debate so in that case um
all the questions are finished and um
we're not entering debate
is there anything else you'd like to add
to councillor haran
no i think that sums it up it's all in
the um
in in the papers presented and we'll be
in action again
next week thank you very much councillor
haran
in that case i'll now ask the corporate
manager governor
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic
vote thank you chair councillors could
you please
open the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
of the agenda screen
and selecting attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue please
click on the blue line to open the vote
thank you not showing
you may need to scroll down
oh
[Music]
oh
chairman i have to say nothing is
happening on my screen
[Music]
um you may need to scroll down i had to
do that
and there's a thin bar on the right hand
side in which to
scroll down yes i'm trying that i can't
make it come up
mine's the same i can't get mine up i'm
afraid
um you do need to hover your mouse
over it and then it will show
well um that would be uh really good
because then we'd really be able to get
those ones with me
if you hover over it the bar will widen
and then you can scroll
yes down trying that john whatever i do
um absolutely nothing comes up i may
have to record my vote um
verbally i'm aware of what to do i've
been doing it but this time it
is not it is not working
madam chairman it's councillor john
osborne i had the same problem so i came
right out of it and
re-logged in again and it's come up and
i've managed to vote okay
thank you thank you john i'm
yes i'm being informed that um modgov
may have timed out so we may all have to
um come out and then go back in again
log back in again
chair you will find that's true i had to
thank you
i think i voted
to to clarify if we've already voted
does that mean you you won't be able to
vote again if you have already voted
your vote councillor lindsay okay so the
councillors that we haven't got are
counsellor ayers councillor busby
cranster grandin councillor holt
councillor and councillor howard and
myself councillor haran
and councillor not letting me back in
okay
so councillor busby would you like to
vote um
now and then we'll add it in manually oh
i'd love to thank you very much yes
four thank you councillor grandin would
you like to vote
manually
4 councillor holt would you like to vote
janice i believe councillor holt has had
to leave the meeting
okay councillor howard these questions
and respond to the petition for up to
three just cancer haran now then please
if you'd like to indicate um i'm voting
for but i may also have voted remotely
um
[Music]
no you haven't you haven't we can see
that councillor so if you'd like to just
vote for that
yes thank
the comprehensive parking strategy would
surely
councillors um we're just going to take
a five-minute
adjournment or a very short adjournment
please
remain at your um computers because the
monitoring officer wants to
say something um so we're just going to
um turn off the screens and um
we'll be back shortly so it's just a
quick adjournment but please stay where
you are
thank you
welcome back councillors
so we're now going to have the result of
the
vote that we just took um so
if i may ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to tell us the result of the vote that
we've just
had thank you thank you chair that was
unanimous
thank you so that was carried we'll now
move on to
item 10b bc
2019 recommendations from the joint
overview and scrutiny committee
i would like to invite council mccraw to
introduce paper bc
2019 and move the recommendations in the
report
thank you thank you chair thank you
chair uh we now come to the
recommendations in this occasion
the joint overview and scrutiny or in
this case baber
overview and scrutiny are making to
baber council
and it was the question of the report i
previously gave on the review of outside
bodies
i'll briefly go through the five
recommendations listed in front of you
and try and explain the circumstances
surrounding those
i don't have access to the full reports
than the reasoning
the minutes for why we did that so i'm
going to be operating off memory
but i can assure members that these were
carefully considered
and good reasons for these
recommendations uh
do exist uh in terms of 1.1
the suggestion that the appointments be
removed
from the appointments the council makes
at its annual meeting
are for the following reasons uh the
baba domestic violence and abuse forum
no longer exists or has been subsumed
into a body
on which the council already has
representation
the east west rail consortium was felt
to
not have direct relevance to the issues
in baber
but was perhaps more of a more interest
to mid suffolk
who also considered that it does involve
i believe some cost but it meets so
rarely
that it's debatable whether there's any
point in baber being involved
the joint waste management board has
also been subsumed
into other functions through the county
council and the
council network operating across suffolk
the suffolk joint emergency planning
policy panel likewise
we have representation on the body that
replaces that
and finally the suffolk rail policy
group to which i have been appointed for
nearly six years
as far as i know has never met in that
entire period
and appears to be completely defunct one
of the reasons might be that in fact its
reason
for existing was to deal with the um
outcomes from major rail incidents and
i'm very glad to say that in that six
year period there haven't been any
um question two 1.2 recommendation is
based on the haven gateway partnership
to which this council was previously
involved but we could find
no evidence um and none was presented to
us despite
our asking for it of what relevance the
haven gateway partnership
had towards the operation of this
council i believe that's also true
of mid-suffolk uh we are of course
recommending that the councils consider
withdrawal i would suggest on the
current basis that there is
no evidence that we were presented with
that would indicate we should
so i would recommend we don't 1.3
uh a member representative be appointed
to home start in line with mid-suffolk
district council
yes i believe this would be something
that could be useful to uh
residents in the council and obviously
we'd have the experience of the
mid-suffolk members to support that
the one recommendation 1.4 was something
we've been trying to work for this is a
process we've been going through for the
last three years
and we honestly believe that feedback
from members to council would help
council in making decisions about
how these appointments are made and why
they're made so we believe that we'd
like to set up a template for
representatives
on these bodies that we appoint to be
able to report back
and that information would then be
presented as part of this annual review
that overview and scrutiny
have been undertaking each year and
finally
a rather important one in our view was
that 1.5 that support and training be
established for
members when they're appointed as these
representatives on these outside bodies
in many cases we are just thrown in
there and we're not really given much
indication of what even
the body determines or deals with
some of them are consultative some of
them are for information but they all
have value
and without training it's difficult to
know
um or guide members in how best
to carry out their responsibilities
i note that there are five separate
voting buttons available for this one
but i would like to propose
here and now that all five
recommendations be considered
on block as one vote in order to save
time
and deal with the slight difficulties we
occasionally have with the uh
voting system so i so propose i ask for
a seconder
thank you council mccraw um yes we
should be able to vote
and block unless there's any reason why
we have to pull
one item out and vote for it separately
i'm sure that will be discussed in
debate indeed
um and may i have a seconder please
madam chairman
i'll counsel him out easy i'll be very
happy to second it
thank you councilman well the easy
you're welcome
um we'll now move to questions um
may remind counselors they might may ask
as many questions
as they wish however they must be
relevant to the subject
under discussion and must be a question
have we got any questions please
councillor arthy have you got a question
please yeah thanks
um it's actually about the joint waste
management board which i'm sure i used
to sit on
um and i thought that also included our
joint waste contract
um with mid-suffolk and used to meet at
the um depot i may have got that wrong i
i thought that councillor malveezy would
have been on that board
but if she's never been to a meeting
because nothing's ever happened
um then perhaps it has been subsumed
into something else i don't know
that was our understanding councillor rc
but in matters in matters concerning
waste management i defer to your
extensive experience in the area
um but councillor malvisi is the current
uh person responsible for that portfolio
i don't know i we understood that the
function of the joist joint waste
management board had been subsumed
into a wider body or perhaps a
differently named body
on which this council already had
representation
i would be fascinated to hear an answer
are you able to
tell us anything about that councilman
malveezy um
thank you madam chairman it's something
new to me so i would suggest that it has
been subsumed somewhere
i've not attended any such meetings i've
not been made aware of any such
meetings um i'm
i work very closely with my opposite
number in mid suffolk
so and if i don't show up
she's always chasing me so yeah i think
i think in honesty counselor malvisi
that its functions
are being dealt with and i would i would
not expect that anybody would not want
them dealt with
um if at some future point if at some
future point the reconstitution of the
joint waste management board is
necessary i'm sure that could be
achieved
absolutely but for the moment we could
see no reason for it
an appointment to be made to what seemed
to be a non-existent body
yes could i come back on that
yes you can thank you yeah i don't know
if we've still got cassandra with us
um but if we have could we ask her
whether there is still a
contract meeting that takes place
um with the contractors and
the opposite number from mid-suffolk it
always uses
i'm sorry counselor arthi uh uh subject
yes um um
cass has gone home yeah she's left the
meeting she's left the building
yeah i'm quite happy to uh
withdraw that particular piece for it to
be revisited at a later date should
members require further information um
it would be a very straightforward
later vote and could take place before
the next uh annual council meeting
uh if that was something that would
satisfy members
maybe we'll um look at that at the end
of the meeting in case anyone else wants
to contribute and and
or has any further information
uh council award you have your hand up
um have you got a question
yes i have and i'm just trying to get my
camera
there you go um it's concerning the
haven gateway partnership i was just
wondering whether we could um
slightly amend the wording of that
recommendation and take the word
withdrawal out and
and perhaps both councils consider their
membership
um withdrawal kind of um
uh predetermines a direction
of travel there um the reason is i know
the haven gateway partnership
it does find it difficult to demonstrate
value um and i know councillor holt um
the the portfolio holder for economic
growth um is concerned about it but
it does have a purpose um uh
it unites the the authorities
on the suffolk side and the essex side
of the store
and i will use the word store and i know
that some of my colleagues might um
bridle at that but um
the thing is in suffolk we're members of
uh new angular lab
uh essex are members of south east lep
haven provides that bridge between the
two
um and also in the
given that we're or potentially there's
uh
going to be a bid for a free port east
which will encompass felix's own
heritage
um it might give a renewed vitality
to the haven gateway partnership i think
any um
withdrawal at the moment might be a a
bit um
premature um uh also of course uh it
will
it'll need um further discussion with
the the various cabinet members
um and and officers but um i just want
to uh
take the word withdrawal out and and
perhaps
the recommendation is considered
withdrawal and this is the point at
which the decision would be made
what i would suggest then if i may
is that we withdraw uh the
recommendation 1.2
completely and that leadership consult
and access get in contact with haven
gateway partnership and ask for some
demonstration
of that value to baber and its future
possibilities
before any further appointment be made
i think that's a reasonable approach and
i would withdraw 1.2 but ask the cabinet
to and just suggest to the cabinet that
they actually
do so just speak to them and see
what we get out of it and how we could
make use of it
i'd be quite happy the point we were
concerned about was the fact that there
was no demonstration of such a thing and
in one occasion
from personal experience i know that a
matter of affecting
my ward although admittedly across the
river in essex
had been effectively kicked into the
long grass
by giving it to the haven gateway
partnership
from whence it never emerged you're
referring to the bridge railway
i'm referring to the manning tree
crossing yes which at a meeting held
including the department of transport
both local mps and everybody else the
matter wasn't dealt with now that's just
an example
of ineffectiveness in my view that i
speak as a personal one but on behalf of
overview and scrutiny
that was the reasoning and thinking
behind it it could be revisited at a
later point
but i think the point is that it should
be um
something that is discussed with the
haven gateway partnership
that some demonstration of value be
supplied
yes i'm happy to withdraw 1.2 completely
um can i um just interject here
the monitoring officer would like to um
say a word
about this thank you thank you chairman
councillors these recommendations come
from the overview and scrutiny committee
therefore they cannot be amended or
withdrawn
they can simply be voted for or against
so unfortunately councilman councillor
mccrory it's not within your gift
to propose those amendments in that case
a separate vote would be necessary upon
each of the items yes i think that will
be the case thank you
i was just trying to simplify matters
and we seem to be drifting into debate
here um councillor davis
i believe you have is is yours a
question or shall we move into
debate no
mine is more debate yeah thank you okay
can can we reserve that for later
absolutely yeah councillor osborne um
you have your hand up yeah thank you
madam chairman it
it's just a clarification really of the
haven gateway 1.2
is a um any financial uh
um situations with baber on this
do is there is a is there a fund that we
have to produce for haven gateway
and incidentally most of the haven
gateway stuff is from
tender and district council as far as i
know
councilman crawd can you answer that
question i believe it is fundamentally
essex-based
thank you have you any other questions
councilman your hands up is that for a
question
sorry madam chairman i've got the same
problem as counselor osborne because my
my hand is showing down oh right okay if
i
do is it now
down it's down thank you
right um thank you
have we any further questions
if not um um
janice robinson would like to say
something to the meeting
could you hold on please everyone thank
you chair
can i just clarify the joint waste board
this was previously a group
of members and officers that met to look
at waste services internally
and it hasn't been in existence for a
number of years it's not to be confused
with the suffolk waste
partnership thank you chair oh
thank you thank you very much for that
point that's
that's exactly it i i i'm afraid that
the individual details of every single
one and we looked through a lot of
bodies
just didn't come to mind grateful for
that opinion
of what that information you saw
clarification yeah absolutely
um so i think now unless someone else
has some further
questions um i think we can move on to
debate councillor davis i believe you
had um something that you want to say to
towards the debate council davis
thank you very much chair yes i would
just uh like to reiterate that i think
having a seat on the haven gateway is
actually very important
especially as council award has
mentioned about the free ports
um i know the suffolk chamber of
commerce
is working very closely with this and
the lep has been mentioned
and i think the the opportunity of
freeport is something that baber
should be very involved with i'm sure
fiona and cass
and michael and councillor halt will all
be on this as well so
while i totally appreciate councilman
mccror's
feelings about the past i think it's
something we have neglected
um maybe we haven't given it as much
attention as as we should have
but i think it's important that we do
have a seat on this table
and i i would throw my hat into that
because um
obviously given my geographical location
as well
will be a at the moment not relevant
but i think it's a very important um
body to be
on thank you thank you councillor davis
uh councillor adrian osborne
yeah thank you thank you madam chairman
um yeah i'm
uh first of all uh i'd just like to say
that
in my experience of living in that part
of
the essex district um i could not see
any
thing that happened uh with haven
gateway that actually
uh would have given anything to suffolk
and i quite agree with our chairman
of ovion scrutiny that um it's
become basically a talking shop i i
i sympathize and and i concur with a lot
of things that uh
councillor davis has said however um if
it doesn't
produce anything for for the district
baba district
i i cannot see the point of of actually
being there
and i'd just like to complete that by
saying i would just like to thank
on behalf of the members of the work
that uh council macro has done
not only on on on this thing but on all
the aspects of uh over scrutiny
in the in the last few months uh
particularly with kovid
as it is thank you very much alistair
thank you
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor osborne i think uh
many of us would conquer with that uh
councilman crawl uh it was just to say
that
um it may not be within my gift to
withdraw
the recommendation of the overview and
scrutiny committee
but of course like anybody else i have
the option to vote against
what i've just proposed bizarre though
that may seem
that might solve the issue and allow us
to take the votes
uh accordingly i'll take advice on that
later
um was there anyone else
counselor horan did you want to speak
yes madam chairman um i i did have
first-hand
experience of the haven gateway um
ten years ago in my position of chair of
the pin mill bay committee we did apply
to them for a grant
and we achieved about 300 000 pounds
from them
which built on all the new hard
the jetty and all the new features and
functions down up here
so at that point um they were very very
useful and contributed um
very well to this side of um the star
estuary in suffolk
and we got on very well with them and
they provided the money for all that to
be built
um so maybe if they were asked again it
could be achieved again
so so they're not totally dormant but it
was ten years ago
but they were very useful and helpful at
that time
thank you councillor haran councillor
arthur have you got your hand up
i have yeah um it's it's partly to
ask um councilman mccraw
exactly what he meant bobby just said
but before i do that
um i asked the question about the um
about the joint
board and i've looked back through some
of my old papers i think the last time
that i sat on that
was about six years ago
and it was a board that was set up after
we had the joint contract with
mid-suffolk for collection
and it was separate to the suffolk waste
partnership suffolk waste partnership i
still sit on
um i helped form it 20 years ago
and i'm still there but the um the
contract board was something completely
different
and it was actually quite useful however
i don't think
it needs to um have a sort of a formal
appointment
i'm guessing that councillor malvizi
would pick up any issues with the
contract as part of her portfolio
so i i'm i'm not going to um oppose
the deletion of it as a as a an outside
body that we should have a
representative on but i'm not quite sure
what councilman mccraw was saying when
he said we can vote against this and
then
what would happen would it then go back
to o and s to have another look at it
is that what he's saying i was referring
there councillor arathi to the
haven gateway partnership
yeah but we if we vote against this we
vote against all of
all of the paper don't we no we we we
would have to take the recommendations
separately and i think there is a
provision for that
within the voting system i had
originally proposed that we vote all
five of them in on block but in the
light of of the possibly
possibly i can't have don't have the
power to withdraw
a recommendation that my committee have
put forward
but i do have the option to vote against
what i just proposed
and we we could take each one in turn
and i believe that would be correct in
government's proceedings
i believe that what we can do is
um just pull that one out and vote for
that that
item separately and vote for the others
as a group can we do that
um i'll just ask the monitoring officer
if i've understood that correctly or not
yes chair your summary is absolutely
right the council can request
that one of the recommendations is
extracted and voted on separately and
then take the rest on block
or you could vote for each one
individually
however that would seem unnecessaries if
the
intention and the feel in the room is to
support the other recommendations
or to vote in the same way on the other
recommendations
thank you well i'm happy with that
suggestion
and i ask my seconder if they are happy
as well
councillor osborne councillor osborne
are you happy
oh councilman malveezy was the secondest
sorry i have apologized
i don't know having great difficulty
with my cursor
me too mine's just gone now i'm
perfectly happy with that
i'll still say thank you um does anyone
else want to join the debate
is that councilman are you um wishing to
join the debate
here no thank you oh right you're
flashing
so in that case um if there's there's no
further debate
i think we could move to the vote so
what we will do
is vote on the single item first
which is i item
1.2 the item considering haven gateway
partnership
and then we'll vote on that first and
then we will come
back again and vote on the other items
end block so if we can now vote
challenge sorry yes sorry just be clear
about what we're voting for when you
take that one out
are we voting for the deletion of the
haven gateway or are we voting for
no we're not okay so how that's a very
good point
um councilman crawl could you
explain what we finally agree to vote on
here
do we have to vote on the actual paper
my understanding of this is would be
that we would vote for
uh recommendation 1.2 first
yes um and then we would vote on block
for
1.1 1.3 1.4 and 1.5
collectively yes so and we have to
vote for 1.2 as this is printed in the
paper
so so as you can see there
um on your um agenda
that that is what we are voting for as
you can see it
in your paper not with any amendments
that were suggested
and can i just add that if members
believe
that we should explore possibilities
with the haven gateway partnership
they should do as i will be doing and
vote against
that recommendation despite the fact
that i've proposed and secondly on
behalf
of my committee
so if we want to
con consider still working with them we
vote against
the motivation yes so
i hope everyone understands um
the way they they wish to vote so
if we can move to the electronic voting
now
for item 1.2 the item considering haven
gateway
partnership you're voting for it as it
stands
in the paper if you consider that we
should still continue
voting up working with them
and and then you vote against
if you wish to vote for the
item as it stands then you vote for
thank you if you'd like to go to your
electronic voting
chair yes my touchpad has given up the
ghost and it's the only means of
accessing the voting screen so i'll have
to vote verbally from now on
okay thank you thank you council i'll
take those votes
um the the manual verbal votes at the
end
and we'll come back to you so
councillors you do need to click on
the plus button and go to um the
modern.gov sign
at the top right hand of your screen and
when it shows in blue please click on
that to open the vote
just for the item 1.2 thank you
councillors we have three votes
outstanding that's councillor barrett
councilman mccraw and my councilman
malvezi please can i have your votes
manually please counsellor
mccraw first please um on the haven
gateway partnership 1.2 i vote
against okay thank you councillor
barrett
um again sorry i've been timed out i
think so
okay thank you and councilman malveezy
can somebody re-read
1.2 yeah so 1.2 so what you're actually
voting for
is if if you you want to consider
withdrawing from the haven gateway
partnership
you will vote for if you don't want to
consider withdrawal from the
haven gateway partnership you're voting
against thank you against
thank you we will bring you the number
shortly thank you
so that is 6 4 21 against
one abstention and chair can i also
remind that we're getting very close to
the guillotine so if somebody would like
to move
that we extend the meeting to consider
the remaining business that would be
very helpful thank you
i'm prepared to so propose i'll second
it madam chairman
thank you councillors
we need so we
we will we will need to vote on
extending the meeting
of course we will
um are we going to do that
electronically
what
no okay i have i have been informed that
um on the extension of the meeting if
we can do it on consensus so in if
if there is anyone who objects please
say it now
otherwise we will continue the meeting
as a matter of consensus
so i'll take that as we can continue the
meeting
thank you everybody um have we had
so thank you yeah so so chair that was 6
4 and 21 against
and one abstention we will now go on to
the rest of the vote
which is the other items so it's 1.1 1.3
1.4 and 1.5 so his councillors can again
move to the vote using the plus button
and when it's when it's turned blue if
they can vote on the remaining
recommendations thank you
hmm
uh jan i'm not able to get back on to
that so i will have to give
you my verbal vote
okay councillor we'll come back to you
in this shortly once i've got the list
of
of who's not been able to do it through
the system
thank you
uh thank you
um chair we're just um waiting for
counsellor heirs councillor barrett and
councilman course so can i have your
votes verbally please
counsellors
yeah i have been trying yes i'm full
thank you
thank you councillor barrett four
thank you and councillor mccraw four
thank you
chair that is 25 4
one against and two abstentions
thank you so that vote is carried
thank you and thank you councillor
mccraw
so we'll now move on to our next item
item 11.
bc 2020
to note decisions taken by the qf
executive during the covid 19 pandemic
period
under delegated powers in accordance
with part two
of the constitution i would like to
invite the monitoring officer
to introduce the report which is for
noting
thank you thank you chair i'm pleased to
introduce the
schedule of decisions taken by the chief
executive under the
urgency powers contained within part two
of the constitution
these are for noting only but i will
just advise the council that these all
related
to urgent decisions that were needed to
assist with the council's response to
the covert 19 pandemic
thank you chair
i'd like to give thanks to our
monitoring officer for that report
item 12 bc 2021
strategic asset management plan 2020
to 2025. i would like to invite
councillor busby to introduce paper bc
2021
and move the recommendation in the
report
councillor busby thank you chair
i'm delighted to introduce our new joint
strategic asset management plan
which provides a strong framework
enabling us to manage our assets
effectively and efficiently the plan
will ensure that we are consistent in
our approach to decision making
whilst allowing property decisions to be
made on the basis of the individual
characteristics of each asset
within the portfolio this council is
ambitious
and we will use our land and property to
help deliver more housing
within our district support the
regeneration of our high streets and
town centres
contribute to carbon reduction and
improve
our residents well-being the council's
strategic priorities and objectives are
to build
great communities for everyone to live
work visit and invest in
this plan is a significant piece in the
jigsaw of delivery
i'd like to thank the officers for the
efforts they've put in in putting this
plan together it is a significant piece
of work
and i'd like to move the recommendations
as shown on the paper 3.1 thank you
thank you um before i call for a second
i'll just read out the recommendations
so that we know what we're
going to be talking to the
recommendation 3.1
is it is recommended that council
approves and adopts
the strategic asset management plan for
2020 to 2025
appendix one including the transactions
and community transfer policies
set out in the strategic asset
management plan
as apprentices a and b
can i have a seconder please
thank you council award now i'll open it
up to
questions uh councillors may i ask
because
you counselors may ask as many questions
as they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question counselors have
you any questions
mandy
i have no um hands raised for questions
we can now move on to debate in that
case
would anyone like to open up the debate
council award yeah i just um uh
as i seconded it um this this is um
timely and something we have really
needed um for quite some time
we will get a really good asset register
out of that
up-to-date asset register of everything
we've got and it will also give us
a good way forward in in being able to
manage those assets
and use them properly to support all of
our um
uh policies and and uh the outcomes we
want to achieve going forward so
uh i i think that there is everything to
gain a lot to gain and nothing to lose
by by doing this so i'm very happy to
see it going forward this year
thank you thank you council ward would
anyone else like to
contribute
councillor rc
yeah i'm sorry it's a question really
not debate um and i should have asked a
little while ago
uh but it's it's really just a question
for councillor busby
um when we decided to do this and i
think it's a great idea um i just
wondered why we put the end date of 2025
it's only a four year plan which seems
quite short
well i think it's just going to be
ongoing anyway
i mean it's 2025 but it starts now
and uh it runs until we revise it which
was a five year
uh revision but i think there will be
revisions during the five years
i mean look this the plan is just the
first
first port of call if you like from this
whole host of work
now starts the real work starts now
writing the plan
which was significant but the key to
delivery is actually doing what we said
we're going to do in the plan
thank you council busby does
does that answer your question counselor
arthi
[Music]
um yes it does thanks very much i'm
fully supportive of what we've done
um i just wondered you know why we
haven't looked a little bit further
forward
but i accept what council of busby has
said um and i'm sure that
having started this um with our
ambitious plans for the future i'm sure
it will be um
amended in due course yeah fantastic
okay
thank you councillor adrian osborne
[Music]
thank you madam chairman and i concur
with everything that
clive has said i believe that uh
davis worked hard over all the years
that i've known him
on on issues such as these and i think
it's in very good hands for him to
deliver another design guide
thank you dave you give me far more
credit than i deserve
put a lot of work into this it was the
officers have been tremendous
yeah and i congratulate the officers as
well thank you
thank you councillor osmond councillor
barrett
[Music]
thank you um it's interesting to note
um 800 other open public spaces
um more information on that is that
little patches of grass at the ends of
roads or is that
it can be yeah a lot of them are those
uh small spaces which are probably not
worth a great deal but
we've we've managed to end up owning
them that's right
so it can be anything from a triangle at
the end of a road of piece of grass
up to something much more significant
okay thank you um i i just you know it's
good to have a plan and
and some structure um and it provides
i'm sure a lot of um a lot of um
structure to
to the way ahead i just i do hope
that now that internal process has
been completed or part of it um that we
can
can see sort of some some tangible um
management of spaces for example there's
public toilets in burkitt's lane in
sudbury that have been
closed for i think over
20 years as far as i'm aware um so it
would be really good if now
that that work shifted to uh delivering
some
um some benefits um and some sort of
disposals
or um or renovations is that
what the plan is well yeah i can't
promise it on on those
so i'm quite happy to turn up with my
marigolds and domestics to see what we
can do about it but
yeah as i said the plan is just the
first first
first step in the process there's a hell
of a lot of work that's got to go on
from now
but recognizing what your assets are and
what we want to deliver
get from them is is an important step
thank you thank you councillor mccraw
thank you chair uh on the subject that
councillor barrett just raised about
those small patches of land
i know from my own experience in my ward
that many of them will be
public open space land constrained by
the planning agreements that have been
entered into and in fact are fully
covenanted so they're not
necessarily disposable in any way but
it's important to
have such an asset register and in fact
finding
find having an idea of what you've got
is essential i commend the report and
also the expertise the council have
gained in recent years
in in actually handling the last two
years particularly
in actually handling our assets and
property management
i think that's been an incredible
achievement of this administration
from my personal observation
yeah we couldn't have done this report
two years ago
precisely thank you councillor
if there's no one is there anyone else
who would wish to
join the debate
if there's no one else who'd like to um
contribute to this debate
we'll then move to the vote i read out
the recommendation
earlier um and so we will now move to
electronic voting i will ask the
corporate manager governors in civic
office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
thank you chair councillors can you
please open the vote in the app
by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the screen
and clicking attendance and voting and
then when the
show's blue can you click on the blue
line to open that vote thank you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
please don't wait for me i still can't
access that um
voting at the moment okay councillor
we'll take your
vote verbally thank you
thank you um
thank you um chair we have um councillor
dawson
and councilman mccraw and councillor
barrett outstanding so
if i could ask for those to
vote verbally that would be that would
be great cancer dawson
okay we seem to have lost cancer dawson
so we'll go on to councillor barrett
yes i i vote for the report
thank you councilman crore very grateful
for the existence of touch screens
for thank you
[Music]
chair that that is unanimous thank you
so that vote is carried thank you
item 13 bc 2022
timetable of meetings from
2021 to 2022
i would like to invite councillor wall
to introduce paper
bc 2022 and move the recommendation in
the report
council award thank you chair um
a short introduction to a short paper
i'd like to present paperbc 2022 the
timetable of committee meetings for
2021-2022
we need to agree the timetable for next
year and i would like to ask you all to
check the proposed dates to ensure that
there is no reason why the meeting
should not proceed as scheduled
if you do have any specific date issues
please let jan robertson know after this
meeting
so i'd like to propose the
recommendation of paragraph 2.1 that the
draft committee timetable for 2021-2022
be approved
and may i have a second to please
madam chairman i'm willing to second or
i propose to second
thank you thank you yeah
good so unless there any questions on
the report
i intend to put the recommendations
straight to the vote
other knee just a quick switch
yes councillor since none of us all have
had any holidays for 18 months
is there a gap in the calendar for us to
uh go
camping in the isle of wight or
something
i haven't had any time off for ages
i think we'd all like shows thank you
that we've ever been busier exactly
yeah counselor owen have you got a
question
yeah slowly this time yes thank you um
i'm a bit concerned about every two
months
is the baba district council
meetings
is it is it am i reading that right that
we're having it every two months
i think that was previously agreed at a
council meeting but i'll ask our
monitoring officer to confirm
that please okay of course yeah no
actually now you're saying i think it
was thank you
chairman if i can just confirm there are
seven
meetings of the full council scheduled
within the committee
the table of meetings um so
therefore there is almost a meeting
every other month but then there's the
additional meeting for the budget
considerations
so it's actually seven meetings over a
12-month period
thanks chair thank you councilman crore
i just would point out as i said at the
time we're always capable of adding an
extraordinary meeting to the uh schedule
and have in fact done so yes we have
thank you any other comments or
so listen if if there are any details
that need
um checking on later in um other than
that we'll go on to
straight to the vote now please
thank you chair again councillors if you
can go to the modern.gov app and click
on the plus sign
when it shows in blue you can click on
the blue line to open the boat thank you
so
okay so we've still we've got
councillors barrack councillor davis
council dawson and councillor plum who
haven't voted yet so i will take your
votes verbally
f4
thank you councilor barrett councillor
davis four
that wasn't councillor barrett oh sorry
that was councillor dawson councillor
dawson wasn't sorry
okay cancer barrett
thank you and councillor plum
okay thank you i haven't voted either
i'm afraid here
okay would you like to give your vote
yes for thank you
sorry for the record that was councillor
mccraw
chair that was unanimous thank you
thank you so that was carried thank you
item 14 motion on notice
item 14a motion received from council
award
council ward would you like to move the
motion
uh thank you chair i won't read the
motion out you've got it there in your
agenda pack but
i'll just um provide a bit of an
introduction baba has a long and proud
association with the jewish community
and was a refuge for children fleeing
persecution
from nazi germany through the whole
through the kindertransport
and these children came to live with
foster families in the district
sadly many of the 10 000 children who
arrived in the uk were never reunited
with their birth parents
who died during the holocaust a painful
reminder of why tackling hate crime is
so important and the potential
consequences that can arise when it is
allowed to go unchecked
on wednesday 27th of january the uk will
mark holocaust memorial day
when we will remember the millions of
people murdered during the holocaust
and in the genocides that followed in
cambodia rwanda bosnia kurdistan
darfur and also those who preceded the
holocaust in the 20th century and
earlier
therefore it gives me great pleasure to
propose that we strengthen our
commitment
to settling hate crime towards jews by
adopting the international holocaust
remembrance alliance definition of
anti-semitism
this definition which was adopted by the
uk government in 2016
outlaws all forms of hatred towards
jewish people including rhetorical and
physical manifestations of anti-semitism
by adopting this standard we will be
sending a clear message that the council
is committed to identifying and stamping
out anti-semitic abuse
as well as supporting our equally our
equality objectives and providing
residents and visitors with reassurance
of that commitment now as i said the uh
it was adopted by the uk government and
a number of councils
up and down the country are also uh have
also adopted it or are also in the
process of adopting it
so i do urge all counsellors to support
this motion and send a clear message to
those who seek to sow seeds of hatred
thank you chair
thank you council award could i have a
second day please
[Music]
counselor yeah thank you madam chairman
yeah this is completely unacceptable
in our society and our communities now
and in the future
and i am very happy to second council
awards
motion thank you madam chairman thank
you very much
we are now moved to debate councils will
only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes and will be timed
can i open it to be eight would anyone
like to start please
counselor own your your hand has been
raised for a long time
are you wishing to join this debate
councillor barrett
thank you um i just like to say yes i
support this
um i welcome the inclusion of the
examples
the types of behavior because i think
that's that's really useful
to be to to really demonstrate what is
unacceptable
to anyone who may not understand the the
plight
faced by people um uh who are being
racially abused
um but what is blood libel
i'm not familiar with that one but um
anyway i support it
thank you councillor barrett anyone else
would like to speak
council mccraw i think many people
would regard this as a matter that
should have been established
and imagine as a matter of fact for all
of us for a very long period of time and
yet
you still come across i do my own life
examples of closet
prejudice those um little hidden
telling comments you can only support
this we're coming up to a memorial for
the holocaust in the next week or so the
day is i think about the negative within
the next two weeks certainly this month
so yes i don't think anybody could argue
against this
thank you council macro
i have no more contributions oh
councillor carpendale
thank thank you chair i mean obviously i
don't see how anyone could not
support this um it's it's astonishing
really and appalling that we even have
to
go to these links to make such
statements uh but i would also like to
endorse the comment that council ward
made
about it the the genocides that are
going on it's not just the holocaust
many years ago when this was first
introduced and
we got consulted as as councillors
about adopting national holocaust day
i was slightly disappointed that we
didn't embrace
all genocides um as as part of this
movement
so i i hope members will remember that
it's not just
um the the outrageous prejudice
and hate crime against jewish people but
against
all um ethnic cleansing to use that
dreadful phrase
and that we we take a stand against
racism in every form
and all its forms thank you
thank you councillor carpendale did
anyone else wish to say anything
in that case um council award is there
anything
oh sorry we now have um councillor
malveezy
council marvel easy did you want to say
something i did
um i do support uh this motion
very much so um i have a mother sitting
not far from me
who was subjected to ethnic cleansing
um and my grandparents
suffered at the hands of first the
partisans
then the communists during world war
ii i know the pain the anguish that they
went through
and my mother still goes through it so
it's not
to be written off it's not to be
forgotten
and i think it's brilliant that we're
actually remembering it and
commemorating it
all of it thank you thank you council
malvisi
unless anyone else would like to
contribute i will now um ask council
oh sorry cancer airs
[Music]
thank you i totally support this
um if anyone um has the time
um there's a wonderful book called the
choice by edith eager
who's actually in a concentration camp
and
that that really does bring it home so
if anyone's got time to read
it's called the choice thank you
thank you
[Music]
so council award is there anything else
you'd wish to add
um no just to to thank my um fellow
councillors for
for their very thoughtful um uh
contributions um it's clear that this is
something that
uh we all can support
and um and it will mean a huge amount
and um i'm gratified that
there has been a a reasonable a very
good in fact debate actually or or made
a short one but
some excellent contributions yes i
believe we all
we all stand behind this so thank you um
in that case we'll go to a vote i can
i would now like to ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors again if you
could go to the plus sign in the top
right hand
of the screen and wait um
a select attendance of voting and then
wait until that goes blue
and then to open your vote thank you
thank you councillors we are still
waiting for councillor barrett
councillor dawson and councilman mccraw
can i have your votes verbally please
counselor barrett four
cancer dawson f4 it's not coming up mine
again
okay thank you and councilman mccraw
four
thank you chair that is unanimous
thank you
sorry um that was a unanimous unanimous
vote so that was carried
thank you item 15 councillor
appointments
are there any changes to policings
so there are no um no changes
so we have now reached the end of the
meeting
it's been a very interesting and a
long but fruitful meeting thank you all
for all your contributions which have
been very lively
um i think we've all enjoyed the debate
thank you all for attending our next
meeting
is tuesday the 23rd of february
2021 at 5
30 and um i look forward to seeing you
all then
thank you very much and have a good
evening
thank you all for attending and for your
contributions
you